Nöööö!!
haben wir quality options?
ja nice
äh strebt hier auch keiner
ah ah ah
Irgendeine Weihnachten habe ich ja an sich ist Weihnachten immer übelst langweilig
Weiß ich es muss irgendwie so eine voice actor eine Gruppe geben die sich auf
damage sounds spezialisiert hat weil damage sounds klingen irgendwie in allen
games in standen weil damage sounds klingt irgendwie in allen games ähnlich
komische archer typ beschnallt
schinobo 2s das gefühl habe ich auch wenn man sich die damage sounds anhört in
allen games am besten waren früher noch in mmos wo es noch so auto attack gab im
endeffekt mehr als mmos noch nicht so dynamisch waren dann gab es dann immer
auto attack sounds
3 stunden am stück habe ich nicht geguckt was das ding macht ist natürlich
nice das ist natürlich nice aber nicht genug mana am start
natürlich echt nice aber wir leveln erst noch ein bisschen
den boss das leuchtet schon so
also damage sounds könnte ich auch machen
jetzt muss man gar nichts machen einfach da stehen
es war gefühlt in allen mmos irgendwie der gleiche sound nicht nur in war das
war irgendwie ist nicht irgendwie haben alle mmos den gleichen sound gehabt also
gefühlt also als gibt es so eine als gibt es also bei da weiß ich bei da kam
sie sich die sounds wirklich gekauft von so einem studio sprich die haben sich
damals so einen als die da entwickelt hat hat irgendein entwickler mal erzählt
mich würde nicht wundern wenn das bei anderen mmos nicht ähnlich war damals
also als da noch keine 30 milliarden budget am start waren die haben sich
damals in da kam die sich so eine so wie der man das so eine so eine stock sound
cd gekauft und haben dann quasi die monster so gemacht
beziehungsweise den sound rausgesucht der am ehesten zu den monstern gepasst hat
und werden wenn man da gespielt hat er weiß manche monstern haben absolut
bescheuerte sounds
noch vier tage hat so sieht es aus aber noch zeit kriegen die kein damage
richtig angeblich macht die attacke drei damage weil das gar maß der damage
ist gar maß
komischer mop kann es gar nichts aber ich autorack mich schneller als der
damage macht
ja und zumindest damals haben die halt wirklich in da sich von so einer von so
einer stock audio cd sich die monster sounds rausgesucht die klangen halt
jemand da hat er echt bescheuerte monster sounds oder wer es gespielt hat die
troll sounds in dem spiel ist kaputt eigentlich
direkt
wenn ich frage was das für ein game ist das habe ich letztens auf steam gefunden
nachdem ich bei dens game im stream gesehen habe das ist quasi so ein bisschen
wie diablo 1 bloß auf schien übel spork ist voll entspannend darum zu stelzen
ich muss mich heute mal ein bisschen ausruhen die ganze zeit irgendwas
gemacht
platz
kann man kein damage machen warum kann man den budd kann damage machen
kalten wir mal kalten geht in allen action
roleplaying hack and slay gedöns monster kalten beste
und ja und ja lasst euch kalten kalten geht immer
umgekaltet
wir dürfen uns bloß nicht fließen lassen
ich archer der baschen oder platzt das schiebt spritzer da eigentlich rum
aber wenn man damage machen
gut
mehr leben ist immer gut kann man nie genug haben die video experience ist
auch geil sehen wir dass auf vollen 144 fps haben
so muss es sein es ist die pc master race experience
auch als hatte ich selbst gestand der kaknub
der leben immer gut
wir mal gespannt ob
irgendwann noch mal in mmo rauskommt
und noch weiter da leuchtet ja
mal gucken
wieder mal gespannt ob irgendwann noch mal in mmo rauskommt
er leuchtet angeblich ob das ist skar maß oder auch noch gold rum
ja ich bin mal gespannt ob irgendwann noch mal in mmo rauskommt
was mich jemals wieder irgendwie länger als ein halbes jahr beschäftigt
es gibt ja irgendwie nix so richtig
wenn man sich mal anguckt bei wo zum beispiel die
leute die die das die das quasi
jahre lang schon gespielt haben
die oder aus selbst die dies nicht jahre lang gespielt haben
die sind irgendwie alle geil auf klassik wo
wobei ich halt
wobei ich halt so meine zweifel hat mit klassik wo sie das machen wollen
weil die sache ist die klassik wo war halt damals geil ich muss sagen ich habe
auch nicht so viel gespielt
ich war mit dark zu beschäftigt damals
klassik wo ist halt die sache das war halt damals klassik das war halt damals
vanilla und zwar neu
und deswegen war das geil
das wird heute nicht
in der gleichen form geil werden
allerdings wird es natürlich die qualität namens des spiel damals hat
aber was ich mich viel eher frage ist
die wollen die das eigentlich mit einem klassikserver machen weil ich mein
der content für wo klassik ist ja beschränkt
der content geht im endeffekt
bis zum
add-on patch
das waren das nächste
blitzkrieg ne ne ne ne wie gesagt ich bin kein großer bauspieler
burning crusade war das das erste add-on stimmts
ob schon
und also sprich bis dahin gibt es eigentlich klassik content
mehr gibt's ja nicht
und da frage ich mich halt wie die das machen wollen weil ich meine die leute
die kennen sich ja heutzutage aus
was heißt
dass die wahrscheinlich
da war so den klassik war konnte dann haben die wahrscheinlich in
spätestens spätestens im halben jahr durch
ist jetzt quasi
der butcher plus
als koch
und das ist auch das meint wie ging das für die ablohung
ja und ich frage mich wie sie das machen weil spätestens im halben jahr haben
die haben die leute die haben war klassik durch im endeffekt
und danach wird es halt nicht mehr wirklich interessant sein
es sei denn sie wollen content für neuen content für klassik machen was ich
irgendwie bezweifle
das heißt im endeffekt bleibt ihnen ja gar nichts anderes übrig
die klassik so eine so eine
so eine session geschichte näher nicht session so eine leather geschichte zu
machen
also quasi es gibt ein reset
nach einem jahr oder nach einem halben jahr
und dann gehts wieder von vorne los
wobei es da halt dann die frage ist
ob das so geil ist weil ich mein mmo macht ja auch irgendwie so die
persistence aus dass halt nicht nach dem halben jahr resettet wird
deswegen kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass classic wolf für die
leute so da so der heilsbringer irgendwie wird
und das ding ist das ding ist
warum ist das immun gegen damage
als mini mobs spawnen will ok
ich weiß halt nicht
ich glaube nicht dass ein classic wolf so
so geil dann wird wie sich das viele vorstellen so die ersten paar wochen bestimmt ja
wobei halt auch die sache ist so die atmosphäre von einem neuen game
kannst du halt nicht kannst du halt nicht wieder und wieder bringen weil
große sache davon ist ja auch dass die leute sich nicht auskennen
auf fack
max max
du willst muss hier weg
ich in die sackgasse
älter
aber warum warum warum ist der damage imun
soll das scheiß
aber warum
wo bist du damage imun
ha
ausgetrickst
ha ha
ha ha so ein scheiß fallen in allen mpgs wie die mobs rein
einfach warten bis immunity abgelaufen ist
door kiten
abgleich ist er da
kannst du gar nichts dagegen machen kack mobs
ich war noch nicht da
ja und ich frage mich halt echt wie sie das bow classic machen wollen
hat das um eine zweifel irgendwie dass das was wird
die rein und raus taktik
ja ich weiß halt nicht wieder wie sie das
wie sie das hand haben wollen irgendwie
auf lange sicht kann es eigentlich nur was werden wenn sie neuen content machen
aber ich ich
die dass halt nicht
das blitz hat irgendwie classic wo content macht
näher und
und ich fände es ja nice wenn es mal wieder
alter kann aber verrecken jetzt
ein mmo geben würde was ich geil finde
da fahren wir dann geht er
mega ab auf
black desert
weil ich halt sagen muss das ist nicht so meins
da hab ich nix gegen random aber das passiert ja nur auf random
weil ich halt übelst glück gehabt mit meinem gear
ich hab nicht gespielt und hab gear wie teilweise leute die zwei jahre durchgekreinet haben
übelst glück gehabt
das loot jetzt gelootet von dem tut oder nicht
und
ansonsten gibt es halt nicht so viel
was ich halt was ich halt an mmos
gut finde was halt viele
neuere
also mmo iterationen ausgaben nicht haben
das
dass es halt so
dezentral ist also sprich
es gibt keine hotspots auf den maps wo sie spieler treffen generell gibt es
bei vielen mmos eigentlich gar kein grund warum sie spieler treffen
müssen
du kannst irgendwie das meiste solo machen
du kannst du du quasi du ex
st und quest ist schneller besser solo als mit gruppe
wenn du dann doch mal irgendwo was machen muss dann ist es instanziert
ich bin ja jeder meinung dass diese ganze instanz wahnsinn so der anfang vom ende
von so spieler interaktion war
das ganze wurde dann nur noch getoppt durch dungeon finder
da also games den dungeon finder haben haben halt komplett
und um das ganze noch zu toppen
server übergreifender dungeon finder das ist eigentlich komplett gegen den
geist von jedem mmo
ich kann ich ich kann keinen entwickler verstehen der ernsthaft
erstens den dungeon finder überhaupt
weil ich in sein game einbaut so ich kann es verstehen weil weil die leute
keine fünf minuten ruhe da irgendwie haben sie mal eine gruppe zu suchen
und vor allem server übergreifender dungeon finder das ist der komplette
witz
das sorgt dafür dass die leute sich auf für die letzten voll spasten
weil ich mein erstens hast die gruppe automatisch gesucht
und zweitens sind die typen auch vom anderen server das heißt du wirst die
wahrscheinlich nie in deinem
mmo leben wiedersehen
und was das halt auch zerstört ist so diese
dieses zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl von leuten die auf einem server spielen
ich mein wenn ich mir das bei anderen bei mmo überlege wo es halt verschiedene
server gab
da war das das das beste erstmal immer der eigene server auf dem man gespielt
hat
das war so da war fand man sich geil es waren schon mal alle leute geil und man
selbst der geilste weil man ja
auf dem richtigen server gespielt hat hat natürlich jeder gedacht
so und danach
war natürlich die die quasi die eigene fraktion oder quasi das eigene
ja die eigene fraktion gespielt war noch mal geiler
also sprich die leute die gleiche fraktion auf dem gleichen server
gespielt haben alle im prinzip die geilsten
und das lustige war man kannte sich dann nach einer zeit auch
was jetzt was ist jetzt bei mmo so in dieser form gar nicht mehr richtig gibt
ich finde es auch nicht gut dass man
da so der hang hingehen zu
rein internationalen servern
ich kann mich da schon mit allen verständigen
es gibt franzosen die generell ja
ich englisch reden
des lfg
was das heißt das heißt
suche gruppe als das auf französisch des lfg
eins was ich auf französisch kann des lfg
und wenn du sie und wenn du sie ärgern willst
dann kannst du schreibste in chat des lfg
und dann schreibste hinter nofr und dann sind hier range pn sicher
des lfg nofrange
da wirst du geflamed
so ist das jetzt hier boss bossstalls
das bossstalls ist
die ich vorher noch mal haben wir irgendwie prunden zum zum leben regeln
ja und das war und deswegen so so ein mmo würde ich mir halt mal wieder wünschen
wo es erstens wo es deutschsprachige server gibt das muss erlegen
also erstens in dem spiel was nicht darauf ausgelegt ist dass auf einem
server 5000 leute sein müssen das funktioniert
das ist blödsinn ja also sprich wurde so eine serverpopulation von 34000 dass
das gut ist
wo es deutschsprachige server gibt und was war es halt irgendwie
so nicht so anonym
ja also ich will
ich will die leute
ich will wissen wer die idioten auf dem server sind und ich will wissen wer die
guten leute auf dem server sind
könntest du mal den unterschied zwischen kat 4 und kat 5 erklären
weiß ich was im kopf auch nicht so genau also
eine sache die daraus resultiert ist die reichweite
also was jetzt gehen
was genau jetzt ein kabel haben muss dass es wie qualifiziert wird weiß ich
auch nicht
aber letztendlich läuft es auf größere reichweite raus wahrscheinlich ist die
schirmung besser und
irgendwie sowas
das ist so ein typisches ding wo ich bei wikipedia gucke was genau der
unterschied ist
zumindest ist
die länge kannst du die kabel länger machen und
zweifelsfall
dann halt auch über längere strecken schnelleres
alles geschreckt
eben jetzt mal in die stadt
hat das nichts mit geschwindigkeit
es könnte halt sein dass du wenn jetzt einmal so wenn du gigabit machen willst
über 100 meter und ein kabel zu scheiß ist das nicht funktioniert
aber prinzipiell ist mit geschwindigkeit nichts zu tun
es gibt eigentlich bei netzwerkabeln plus zwei
grundsätzliche dinger
hast du vier paare was eigentlich
bescheuert ist aber dann geht maximal fast internet
100mbit mehr geht nicht
acht paare
acht adern
nicht acht paare schwachsinn
vier paare also acht adern
ähm
gigabit
das ist eigentlich das was man sich merken muss
und
der unterschied ist dass man mit
acht adern
dass man
100mbit netzwerk machen kann plus
über vier kabel poe
bei gigabit ist das anders bei gigabit ist
poe und daten auf den gleichen leitungen
verschlüsselung
kabel wird sich ja wohl kaum verschlüsseln oder
glaube ich also
schirmung
verstehe ich ja
äh aber verschlüsselung kann ich mir nicht vorstellen wie soll das kabel das verschlüsseln
da geht strom drüber
ok skillpoint ähm
leben oder mana
das haben sie in dem spiel echt cool gemacht im prinzip verlierst du nichts
also wenn ich das skille
kann ich in die stadt mir auch den punkt noch holen
aber wir sind warrior wir brauchen leben
oh gehen wir mal in die town
und laber mal mit dem fake deckard cain
ganz lot
weil ich den musik
ja ja
hier dann können wir das noch anlocken
haben wir denn für karten lohnt sich das noch einen anzulocken
geld haben wir im endeffekt eh genug
rüsse
also das kann nicht sein
es war so ein kabel kann an sich nichts verschlüsseln
und kabel ist halt das was das wort sagt
stück kupfer oder stück ja meistens kupfer
das kann nichts verschlüsseln das muss irgendwie auf einer logischen ebene oben
drüben über oben drüber passieren
so
und zwar unsere skill points ab
sp ist gut
man kann sich was abkratzen
habe ich nicht gewirbt man könnte wirklich könnte mal meine meine health potions
upgraden
ich habe letztens auf amazon gesehen
zwaden das war
hi end gold
bach
das war total
knackt es hat irgendwie 300 euro gekostet oder so
es hat irgendwie 300 300 euro gekostet und war irgendwie so ein meter so ein meter kabel
ja so was in der richtung war das total total wir ja irgendwie so eine mehrfach steckdose
für 170 euro oder hier irgendwie so ein so ein 90 euro klinken stecker oder
so total hängen geblieben eigentlich
gold usb sticks
ja die sagen ja die sagen ja die vorteile von einem gold kabel ist nicht genau genau
dass das was paratrooper schreibt die sagen ja der vorteil von einem gold kabel ist im
defekt dass die kontakte nicht oxidiert weil man halt sagen muss scheiß drauf also ich
habe so viele kabel ich habe nicht ein eins wo irgendwie der klinken stecker kaputt ist
selbst wenn für den preis von dem gold kabel kann ich mir auch einfach 80 normale kabel
kaufen dann reicht ein gold stecker richtig das ist das ist total das ist einfach bullshit
das ist dass die dass die leute sich einreden können sie sind mehr high end und geiler
gemana potions brauchen wir nicht health potions können wir auf jeden fall upgraden das ist
nicht schlecht kostet nicht viel aber acht health potions das ist schon mal sehr praktisch
was kann man dann sonst noch upgraden was sind das ground effects gibt es bis jetzt
nicht so schild schild upgrade bringt mir was auch 50 prozent block schoss ist natürlich
sehr nice und die karte ist glaube ich auch ganz nice aber ich steht selten zu komplett
nah an den gegnern dran also können wir upgraden das kostet ja auch alles dann mehr mana zum
ausrüsten das bringt uns gerade cool da zu benutzen upgraden wir upgraden werden wir
unsere health potions ist auf jeden fall nicht verändert was bangt man nicht auf ping
den was willst du bang auf ping was kosten das nächste upgrade da brauche ich noch mehr
rooms den können wir noch upgraden aber kostet dann zwei mana ich habe zu wenig ich brauche
erst mal ein bisschen mehr loot noch das war glaube ich nicht aufladen weiter gehts
das macht doch übelst bock das ist mega entspannt ein bisschen durch die dundas stellst
und es ist es ist halt nicht so komplett hack and slay mäßig wie wie das jetzt pass
of exile ist wo du nur rumrennst es ist es ist der butcher oder dass er butcher heißt
weil blitz an das koffe rein drauf hat wahrscheinlich
oh das ist ein enrage gegner muss man aufpassen
moment was der nicht getroffen
ich doch die boots anziehen sollen für kraut effekt und effekte
land fertig machen glhf wie ich darf denn immer hinten wenn er da steht sollen das
achso ist nur ein schlüssel langweilig ja auch mal wieder auf das ursprüngliche thema
zurückzukommen wo ich mich gerade rüber ausgelassen haben mmo ist wie gesagt ich
würde mir echt wieder ein mmo wünschen was man noch mal zurück was man halt einfach
eine weile spielen kann und was bock machen was nicht so anonyme ist und wo man einfach
wo man einfach auch ein lockt um um sie gelten schätze anzug irgendwas so in der rechnung
oder ich hatte gern mittelalterlich angehaucht ist immer ich mag irgendwie so dieses mittelalter
oder was heißt mittelalter fantasy scenario was ich halt so ein bisschen am europäischen
mittelalter orientiert das könnte könnte auch ruhig zwerge drolle elfen krasse nicht
gesehen geben das ist ganz gut aber kein kein was ich nicht mag so übertriebener stelle
es mit rum fliehen und raum schiffen und es ist einfach nicht mein setting
es kein besseres älterste oder älterste oder habe ich die beta gespielt und das wirkte
so so undurchdacht an vielen stellen mittlerweile soll es ja angeblich ganz gut sein vor allem
solo wo wir wieder beim thema sind solo mmo ist das feuer macht nicht wirklich damage
als kämpfe das game können sie auch auf dem ipad oder so rausbringen das wird glaube ich
echt nicht schlecht klappen ja das verstehe ich bei so auch nicht das haben die ja auch
groß angekündigt mit als quasi geistiger damals als geistiger nachfolger von da pvp
und hast du eine komische zone ohne jegliche bedeutung und und sack ich im pvp gameplay
für arsch ein bisschen wie gilt vor zwei wo im prinzip es überhaupt keine ausweckung
hat auf das game ob pvp oder nicht es gibt eine pvp zone die kein mensch juckt das verstehe
ich halt nicht das ist aber halt weil man weil man sich nicht verscherzen mit den leuten
dann danach die motto nein mein mein mein realm kriegt gerade oder oder meine fraktion
kriegt gerade den pvp auf den sack ich habe jetzt nachteile das kann doch nicht sein wenn
ich nach der arbeit einfach nur ein locken will und ein paar quests machen dann darf
es doch nicht sein dass ich nachteile also ich hoffe mal es gibt wieder einen es gibt
mal wieder einen hersteller der die kohle hat und den mut hat da ein bisschen ein bisschen
drauf zu scheißen weil manchmal und das klingt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen aber ich glaube
manchmal muss man auch casuals ein bisschen überzeugen dass es für sich auch nicht schlecht
ist wenn ein game ihn nicht alles in den arsch schiebt das wirkt erstmal blöd und ich meine
damit jetzt nicht per man das per man das ins spiel für sich backen sondern dass das
ich mein für casuals ist es auch cool wenn du mal eine sache alleine nicht hinkriegst
und du in einer guten gilde bist du bist dann mit einer 5er oder 6er gruppe aus der gilde
machst ja da muss man halt vielleicht auch mal bis zu wochen erwarten bis genug leute
und sind aber um so geiler ist es ja letztendlich dann vor allem fördert das halt auch dass
man irgendwie paar leute kennen auf dem saubern weiß wer was taubt und wer es sagt ja erstmal
schon reingerannt hat sich ausgepasst ist bodas das wird schon wieder wünschen also
ich habe jetzt ja ich habe mit farben haben wir viele mmos durchprobiert also wie gesagt
wir kennen uns ja aus da schon ewig her und wir haben was haben wir gespielt ich krieg
das gar nicht mal zusammen rift haben wir gespielt als es neu war so haben wir nicht
zusammen ich habe nur die beta gespielt ich krieg es echt gar nicht mehr zusammen was
war alles alles müll die das einzige game was ich an sich ganz cool fand war also danach
war eigentlich final fantasy 14 ist das ja genau 14 und das problem war final fantasy
14 war erst ist das ein mega kacke und schatten und danach er quasi die welt um die hälfte
verkleinert haben dass sie das wieder ordentlich hinkriegen und dass sie ein fehler gemacht
haben den alle also sie hatten erstens war wieder den dungeon finder und sauber übergreifen
was schon mal kacke fand und sie haben ein fehler gemacht den viele so sagen wir mal
zu kerbe mmos machen und das ist dieses dieses ich weiß gar nicht wieder das mmo fachwort
dafür ist so dieses verstecken hinter in game währung also so nach dem motto wir haben
leider zu wenig high end content und wir wissen auch dass den high end content quasi erst
die masse der casuals in drei monaten sehen wird und eigentlich viele nie sehen werden
deswegen machen wir uns da nicht so viel mühe und können auch nicht so viel produzieren
und dann haben sie halt den fehler gemacht den viele anderen mmos auch gemacht haben
wo dann letztendlich eben auch so die die die der kern der spieler basis irgendwann
auch also die leute die das halt gesuchtet haben weg gerannt ist weiß ich wie es jetzt
mittlerweile ist war damals so sie haben sie haben quasi so in game währung eingeführt
wo man pro woche bloß keine ahnung du hast dann für eine rüstung hast du irgendwie
weiß du bist du du bist nicht in den dungeon rein und hast einfach das ding dreimal am
tag gefahren bis du dann irgendwie deine rüstung oder so hat es nein du musstest den dungeon
quasi zehnmal machen zehn tage oder so und durftest den irgendwie nur zweimal am tag
machen und du hast dann maximal am tag 60 xy währung bekommen und pro woche nur maximal
so viel währung das heißt du konntest dir selbst wenn du 24 7 gespielt hättest nicht
mehr als ein rüstungsteil die woche kaufen was ich auch der normale casual kaufen konnte
der quasi nur eine runde spiel zwei oder so das ist so eine so eine sache dann dann
dann sitzen halt die leute da die das mmo wirklich spielen wollen und können nichts
machen und das ist das und das ist das problem wenn man sich komplett auf auf so pve monster
was ist das hier eigentlich monster club content konzentriert der ist halt aufwändig herzustellen
da musst du halt auch so dinge machen und und wenn du es machst dann hast du das problem
dass die die die guten quasi nach einer woche durch sind wenn du es nicht beschränkst
deswegen muss ein gutes mmo eine ansicht nach eigentlich einen wicht in den pvp system
haben das motivation bietet und einfluss auf das spiel hat also zum beispiel dass man
halt in pvp dinge erobern kann die dann dem der kompletten fraktion was bringen oder
sowas und irgendwie sowas so was fehlt und deswegen haben wir auch final fantasy da nicht
lange gespielt war dann irgendwann fertig wir waren dann durch waren durchgespielt und
man halt sagen muss wie man sollte halt in der mmo nicht durchspielen können in dem
spiel schon mal gar nicht alleine das ist halt so die sache und denke ob da mal wieder
irgendwann einer sich was traut ich bin auch da sich man braucht gar nicht so über das
ist halt die sache viele leute wünschen sich quasi pvp so diesen diesen pvp nicht kontent
so diese sondern diesen pvp nicht sorry pvp vergesst das pvp also monster fashion diesen
pvp content der so so durchgestylt ist quasi du hast jetzt ein piraten schiff rate dann
hast du ein was weiß ich dungeon untergrund fallen ist closer rate danach also wisst ihr
sowas dass ich bin da eigentlich das muss eigentlich gar nicht sein erstens es müsste
gar nicht super instanziert sein sondern ich finde ich finde world dungeons eigentlich
viel cooler halt wo wir dabei sind oh moment boss der wirfkarat nicht vergiftet lassen
ich bin unzingelt ich muss weg
wirklich können tut der typ aber nix er kastet irgendwas warum darf der eigentlich durch
die mitte laufen und ich nicht was was soll das das war nicht da sag gleich noch was
selber kann ich theoretisch den ganzen tag drüber dabei
ist das auch nochever
Oh fuck, die machen ordentlich Damage.
Und und und ist er down?
Etzer Splatter in Karotten.
Loot!
Oh Loot, nice, das Loot ist sehr viel.
Deine Meinung zu Ashes of Creation?
Da muss ich erstmal nachgucken, was das für ein MMO war.
Muss ich nicht, ich muss gleich nochmal nachgucken, was das war.
Bin ich ganz sicher.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Rune.
Oh, ist das eine Legendary, sehr nice Legendary Card, da muss man gleich mal ins Dorf das
Ding indemnifizieren.
Rune.
Hier ist nichts mehr, Ashes of Creation, ähm, ich, ich bilde mir ein, das war doch das MMO,
wo sie, wo sie im Vorfeld auch wieder erzählt haben, was sie für tolle World-Events haben
und, und im Endeffekt sich dann rausgestellt hat, das wird alles nicht so, oder bring ich
das durch.
Wird heute noch, progress kann sein, aber eigentlich muss ich mich heute mal ein bisschen
ausruhen.
Ich hab die ganze, ganze Zeit eigentlich irgendetwas gemacht, immer, immer.
Was da ist, wenn dir das gefällt, Tantrum 1995, da oben ist noch ein Viech, ich guck gleich
mal, was das war, oder ist Ashes of Creation das, wo man älter wird, wo man älter wird
und, und irgendwann dann mal richtig spielen kann, war das das?
Ich guck jetzt mal, warte mal, ich guck mal, was ist jetzt genau gewesen, ich kann mir
das immer nicht merken.
Ashes of Creation, welches war das denn jetzt noch mal?
Das war doch das doch mit dem Älterwerden, ne?
Ne doch, das ist das mit den komischen World-Events, die da nicht so geil waren.
Das hab ich doch, da haben wir doch damals ein Video zusammen geguckt.
Das ist das, wo sie erzählt haben, so nach dem Motto, ja die ganze Welt gibt es immer
wieder irgendwelche Events und dann, und dann wird die ganze Welt immer, immer was los
sein, überall.
Da gab es schon andere MMOs, die das probiert haben.
Es wäre cool, wenn es klappt, also ich will das nicht schlecht machen, ich, ich, ich würde
mir wünschen, dass es wieder klappt und es geile MMOs gibt, die man, die man halt spielen
kann.
Ups, Moment, warum kann ich mein Meme-Tool nicht aufmachen in dem Game?
Hier doch.
Unlock Card Slaughter, ich glaub das brauchen wir erstmal nicht mehr.
Identify Card, wo 5000 kostet, das ist natürlich schon ordentlich, egal, mal gucken was es
ist.
Karma Assists, like, ok und was macht es jetzt?
Bestimmt Mana oder so.
Distance, Spawn, Electric Brawn oder so, äh, aah, ich bin immun gegen, ich bin immun
gegen, äh, gegen Poison Slow Free Stun für 15 Sekunden, ähm, und was noch?
Die Shockwave für irgendwie Gegner und ich spawne Electric Balls, ok also ich mein das,
das wichtigste hier dran ist wahrscheinlich, dass ich immun gegen Poison Slow Free Stun,
das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr praktisch, wenn ich wieder mit in die Gegner reinrenne.
Das equippen wir jetzt einfach mal, äh ne ich kann es noch nicht equippen, weil ich
noch nicht Level 12 bin.
Dann equippen wir das wenn ich Level 12 bin.
Haha, Milchbarn, das hab ich mir auch gefallen, ich, ich bin der Ansicht, dass es bei MMOs
gar nichts radikal Neues braucht und diese, und die ganzen, die quasi so super innovative
Sachen probieren, sind jetzt ja auch irgendwie gescheitert in letzter Zeit, in den letzten
Jahren immer.
Das Amazon MMO, oh stimmt, da kam, da war ja auch was, stimmt, ja da bin ich, da bin
ich auch gespannt drauf.
Hab ich den Level Up gekriegt oder so, ne, die brauch ich noch bis zum Level Up, a nicht
viel.
Ist die Legendary Karte, oh ne, die Legendary, die kann ich nicht upgraden, das ist, ne,
die braucht zu viel Level für, haben wir irgendwas sinnvolles upgraden, Tilt, ah ne, mal gucken,
machen wir erstmal weiter, gelzen wir nochmal ne Runde weiter, weg zu, so ich hab da mit
allen gelabert, können, gibt's irgendwie den Easter Egg, dass man, dass man die Raben
irgendwie des Game of Thrones eben abspielen kann.
Könnte ich jetzt grad nicht in der Lage zu, das hinzukriegen, hab ich, hab ich im Stream
gesehen, geht irgendwie.
Hast du Meta in 2 gespielt, nein, nein, will die Tau nicht visiten, weg, 44 minuten, oah,
44 minuten, jetzt wollen sie, wollen sie aber wissen, ey, 44 minuten Dungeon, oah, aber
es kann nur ein bisschen, so, mindestens, aber wir gucken einfach wie die Tau.
Ich leike das Game ein bisschen, das fällt mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Jetzt nicht.
Aber auf das Amazon MMO bin ich auch mal echt gespannt drauf.
Goatman. Gibt's auch in jedem Hack'n'Slay. Gibt's Goatmans.
Ghosts.
Durchwände.
Aus Korpses.
Uns sind Cold.
Moment, ich hab doch mal eine geile Axt equipped.
Oh nee. Die, die, die Cold AE.
Sagt er aber.
Da muss ich mal gucken, ob ich da eigentlich eine Karte habe, gegen das ich gefriest werden kann.
Ja, ich equipe mit Level 12 einfach meinen Legendary, äh, Trank.
Gibt's, gibt's die Probleme nicht mehr.
Ach, die Burning Axe überhaupt irgendwas?
Äh, öh, öh, öh, öh.
Ja permanent. Permadeath bzw. Gier verlieren beim sterben ist so eine Sache.
Das muss schon wirklich sehr durchdacht sein, dass das, ja vielleicht, dass man sich dann irgendwelche Items locken kann oder so.
Dass man sagen kann, hä? Ähm, ich beleg die jetzt mit, ihr könnt mir ja in die Ingamewelt einbauen, so nach dem Wort.
Warte, ja, brauch jetzt so ein Special Zauber auf die Waffe, dann kann die nicht von mir mehr entfernt werden, oder so, beim Looten.
Weiß ich, gibt's ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
New Cards Usable, jupp, ich weiß.
Frage ist nur, was tauschen wir dagegen?
Was?
Warte.
Ich bin.
Mach mal die Axt.
Okay, ne, das muss mal ein bisschen anders.
Ei.
Was macht mich immun gegen Freeze, Poison?
Brauche ich brauche aber noch einen neuen Card Slot, dass ich die Axt wieder reinpacken kann.
Okay, also man hat auf jeden Fall genug seinem Gold hier zu tun.
Au.
The Gold Man.
Und doch, die Axt bringt richtig was.
Die Axt bringt richtig was.
Mach wieder die Axt dran.
Das andere muss ich erst in der Stadt auffüllen.
Wie viel Charges kostet das eigentlich einsetzen?
Charges.
Was kann man eigentlich dann machen, wenn man in der Stadt wieder seid?
Au, um was geflogen.
Also bei dem Amazon MMO bin ich mal gespannt.
Wie gesagt, ich würde mir halt echt mal wieder ein Game wünschen, wo du einfach 5 Jahre spielen kannst, so nach dem Motto.
Oh ne.
Resource.
Da haben wir grad mal Freezer, dann hat irgendjemand den neuen Tränkenballfilm.
Gesehen ist der überhaupt schon raus.
Kannst du doch jetzt irgendwann kommen? Haben wir schon?
Sagt wahrscheinlich.
Guck mal, es brennt.
Multishot brennt Skelett.
Gerade wird alles kaputt geklickt.
Das ist ein Boss, deswegen hält er so viel aus.
Warum heilt er sich? Wie soll das?
Glaubt er sich einfach zu heilen?
Hekt.
Oh, Loot.
Ja, die Axt ist super. Die Axt macht die Geister übelst schnell kaputt.
Seit wann entwickelt Amazon Games? Seit es angekündigt ist, glaube ich.
Das ist aber schon ein halbes Jahr oder so her.
Da bin ich wirklich gespannt drauf, auf das Amazon MMO.
Das erste, was ich darüber gelesen habe, las ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Hab ich was vergessen, da klitzert es oben.
Das kann man aufmachen.
Aber nix.
Das ist ja nicht so schlimm.
Das kann man aufmachen.
Haben wir alles? Nee, haben wir nicht.
Ein Sarkophag habe ich noch vergessen zu öffnen.
Ich wusste ja nicht, dass man das aufmachen kann da oben irgendwo.
Stimmt, das ist ja CryEngine.
Ja, da war was.
Ich erinnere mich.
Man kann ruhig einen kleineren AE haben, wenn es abkratzt.
Man kann auch die Maus gedrückt halten.
Gut, dass ich das jetzt gecheckt habe.
Ich klicke mich hier gerade kaputt.
Aber es war so geil, wenn es mal wieder ein richtig gutes MMO gäbe.
Vor allem auch eins, wo sich halt nicht...
Also die Entwicklung...
Ich muss doch mal anders anfangen.
Die Entwicklung bei vielen neuen MMOs war ja bisher so.
Die waren übelst gehypt.
Oftmals weil die sinnloserweise als WoW-Konkurrenz promoted wurden.
Ich glaube kaum, dass ein MMO Erfolg haben wird, was quasi einfach WoW nachbaut.
Weil dafür gibt es WoW.
Also z.B. so ein 3-Fraktion...
Was geht mit dem ab?
3-Fraktionen MMOs gibt es z.B. zwar viel zu wenig.
Das, was halt vielen MMOs in den letzten Jahren so das Knick gebrochen hat,
die waren halt quasi übelst gehypt am Anfang.
Denk mal an Dings hier. Wie hieß das? Wild? Nee.
Das ist Science-Fiction MMO. Wie hieß das denn? Ich hab's vergessen.
Wild...
Star? Nee. Wie hieß das denn? Wildstar! Genau. Das ist es.
Was dann irgendwie nach 2 Monaten keine Spieler mehr hat.
Und mittlerweile irgendwie free to play sind wieder immer noch keine Spieler.
Und das ist halt... Die haben halt das Problem gehabt.
Die haben es ultra gehypt.
Die haben angefangen und festgestellt,
es ist halt nicht das, wie es beworben wurde.
Oder halt nicht... Den Hype nicht gerechtfertigt.
Und sind abgehauen.
Die richtig guten MMOs, die sind eigentlich gewachsen mit der Zeit.
WoW hatte auch den mega Hype als es rausgekommen ist.
Konnte aber zumindest das für die meisten Leute erfüllen.
Und noch mehr Leute anlocken.
Die quasi MMOs starten mit vielen Spielern.
Und nach ein paar Monaten keine Spieler mehr haben.
Man hat es auch bei Final Fantasy XIV gesehen.
Da war es auch so, weil es ist auch ein MMO, was sich jetzt relativ lang gehalten hat.
Und auch viele Leute glaube ich noch spielen.
Auch wenn wir schon mittlerweile zu aufgehört haben.
Aber wir spielen glaube ich immer noch recht viel.
Da war es auch so. Start verkackt, keine Spieler.
Und danach langsam Spielerbase aufgebaut.
Der Spawner des Games ist nicht schlecht.
Das bietet dann auch dem Hersteller der Chancen.
Wenn es quasi so eine Rampe hat von unten nach oben.
Und nicht von oben nach unten.
Wie es bei vielen MMOs, die über halb sind, rausgekommen ist.
Das Spiel muss gut sein und muss sich halt mit der Zeit rum sprechen.
Auch dass es taugt.
Und nur so bindest du dich halt auch langfristig dran.
Weil die Leute davon überzeugen, dass dein Spiel was taugt.
Und nicht nur eine Eintagsfliege ist.
Weil wer will in einer Eintagsfliege...
Fuck.
Muss weg hier.
Wer will in einer Eintagsfliege 800 Stunden investieren.
Und dann geht es free to play nach 3 Monaten.
Warum bin ich eigentlich gefriest, wenn ich durchs Feuer laufe?
Warum kann ich gefriest werden, wenn ich durchs Feuer laufe?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Uhhh.
Wurde vor allem echt...
Weil du das eingestellt hast.
Das meine ich ja.
Du musst die Spieler davon überzeugen.
Warum soll ich da so viel Zeit reinstecken?
Vor allem baust du halt auch kein Vertrauen.
Dazu auf...
Ah was.
Die guten MMOs sind entweder fail gestartet oder langsam gestartet, was man Bawau nicht wirklich sagen kann, aber Bawau war die Rampe auch so.
Es hatte einen Hype, es hat die Leute gehalten, es hat rumgesprochen, es ist geil und es sind immer mehr, bis zu irgendwann 10 Millionen geworden.
Mittlerweile nicht mehr, mittlerweile ist es umgedreht.
Und so wie es jetzt da ist, starten halt viele MMOs heute schon.
Die kommen über halb des Todes raus und dann stellen die Leute fest, eigentlich ist es scheiße.
Zu Bawau kann ich nicht sagen, ob ich zu wenig gespielt habe.
Ich habe bloß ein bisschen Klassik sauber gespielt, bis es plötzlich dicht gemacht hat.
Och, Schamane.
Stellst.
Ich glaube auch, dass diese Early Access Geschichte nicht dazu führt, dass die Sachen die Leute mehr anspricht.
Weil ich meine, kommt ein Spiel raus, ist vielversprechender, hat einen gewissen Hype.
Man stellt fest, es ist doch nicht so geil.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch noch nicht fertig.
Und dann verschwindet es quasi von der Bildfläche.
Guck mal, wie viele Early Access Titel werden erstens nie fertig.
Und zweitens, wie viele Early Access Titel sind, nachdem sie aus dem Early Access rausgekommen sind,
noch überhaupt irgendwie mal im Gespräch.
Die meisten Early Access Titel kommen raus als Early Access, da wird ein bisschen drüber geredet.
Und dann ist es in den Köpfen der Leute so, wie das Spiel ist doch rausgekommen.
Da unten waren wir schon.
Das Spiel ist dann raus und dann ist es gut.
Die meisten Early Access Titel, davon darf es ja nicht fertig werden.
Es gab nur ganz wenige Games, die dann Early Access rausgekommen sind.
Und dann quasi dieses normale Game ist raus und wächst.
Die meisten Early Access Titel, die rausgekommen sind, hat der richtige Lounge echt keine Sau mal interessiert.
Und viele Early Access Dinge werden halt nicht fertig.
Also ich glaube schon, dass man heute noch erfolgreiche MMOs machen kann, wenn man es nicht macht.
Wenn man halt auch ein bisschen Mut dazu hat, es nicht gar zu Kehrbeermäßig zu machen.
Geiles Wort.
Moin Alex Mingar.
Und das hätte ich halt einfach auch wieder gern, das wäre übelst geil.
MMOs sind zu teuer zu entwickeln.
Das ist geschenkt.
Deswegen bin ich auch der Ansicht, das habe ich ja noch gar nichts zu gesagt.
Deswegen bin ich auch der Ansicht, dass die einzig guten MMOs Abo MMOs sind.
Da wird mir der Fabian mit Plague Desert wahrscheinlich widersprechen, allerdings, wenn ich mal überlege,
da für Kohle reingebuttert wird, da kann man auch sich ein Abo kaufen, da muss sich keiner beschweren.
Ja, die EA MMOs waren aber auch scheiße.
Das erste, was wir hatten damals, war allerdings hier Warhammer.
Und Warhammer haben sie komplett vergeigt in der Entwicklung.
Also das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Warhammer sollte eigentlich ein PvP, drei Fraktionen MMO werden.
So ein bisschen wie Dark, das war ja auch von den gleichen Leuten damals.
Und die haben sich halt die übelsteuere Warhammer-Lizenz gekauft.
Und dann ist ihnen eingefallen in der Entwicklung, dass es ja nicht sein kann, dass wir einen PvP-MMO machen mit drei Fraktionen.
Da haben sie eine Fraktion gekattet und dafür halbherzige PvE-Inhalte entwickeln lassen.
Die Warhammer-PvP-Inhalte waren halt jetzt scheiße.
Dann, was hatten die EA noch für MMOs gehabt?
Star Wars? War das? War das? Nee.
Doch, ne?
Star Wars, ja ja, doch Star Wars.
Ja, das haben sie auch verkackt.
Wobei ich dazu überhaupt nicht sagen kann, habe ich nie gespielt, weil einfach Science-Fiction-MMOs noch nichts für mich sind.
Und ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher, ob du heutzutage so sehr mit einem Star Wars-Game das punkten kannst.
Ich meine, klar, das hat letztendlich genauso genau...
Es gab doch auch ein Star Trek-MMO, ne? Gab es auch noch.
Das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich. Ich meine, es hat beides, viele Fans.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie viele junge Fans das hat.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Fans sich von Star Trek und Star Wars nicht tatsächlich den MMO davon...
Ich war nie ein großartiger Fan, muss ich sagen, vom Star Wars-Universum.
Und wenn es ähnlich gelaufen ist wie bei Warhammer, die Entwicklung, dann wundert mich nichts.
Wie gesagt, Warhammer war als drei-Fraktions-PvP-MMO geplant.
Und EA hat während der Entwicklung zu Mystic Anatomic gesagt,
Scheiß drauf, dritte Fraktion kacken und billige Kack-PvE-Inhalte entwickeln, die kein Mensch braucht.
Jawoll! Und wer hätte das gedacht? Die Spieler haben gesagt, Spielzeug.
Wer es spielen will, es gibt einen halbwegs aktiven Freesharter, den ich letztens gesehen habe.
Aber trotzdem, er ist komplett für den Arsch.
Wow!
Chargeder.
Alles in Baro.
Deswegen, man muss kein WoW-Killer machen, das geht eh nicht.
Das wird es nicht geben in der Form.
Man kann nicht einfach WoW nochmal machen und dann...
Nee, so funktioniert das nicht.
Oh, das sind ganz schön viele Mops hier.
Was? Casino? Nee, ich glaube, Casinos viel mehr, wenn wir nicht sehen.
Eigentlich mache ich das nur, weil ich mich mal einen Tag ein bisschen ausruhe.
Ich habe ja trotzdem, da ich eine ganze Zeit Urlaub habe, immer irgendwas gemacht.
Permanente.
Da muss ich einfach mal ein bisschen Entspannungsstellen machen.
Mops bashen.
Aber kein YouTube-Videos. Ja, ich weiß.
Und deswegen glaube ich auch, dass ein kleineres Team ein erfolgreiches MMO machen kann.
Allerdings hoffe ich mit Abo-Modell.
Und ich glaube auch, dass Abo-Modell eigentlich das ist...
Ich weiß, es ist irgendwie ein bisschen überholt in der heutigen Zeit.
Zumindest sagen das alle. Alle sagen, das Abo-Modell ist überholt.
Aber ich bin der Ansicht, dass ein Abo-Modell Vorteile hat für...
Letztendlich alle Beteiligten.
Ich meine für den Hersteller, der weiß einfach, was reinkommt.
Wenn er sich seine Monats-Abo anguckt, dann weiß er ungefähr, wie viel Geld er pro Monat die nächsten paar Monate kriegen wird.
Es kommt ganz selten vor, dass auf einmal 900% die Abo kommen.
Und die Spieler wissen letztendlich auch, was sie kriegen. Sie kriegen nämlich alles, was drin ist.
Sie kriegen alles, was drin ist, zu den gleichen Konditionen und zu den gleichen Voraussetzungen wie alle anderen auch.
Was ist der große Vorteil von einem Abo-Modell?
Bin ich.
Und letztendlich ist es ja so, dass die Games dadurch, dass sie free to play sind und irgendeinen Shop haben oder so,
für die weißen Leute auch gar nicht billiger sind.
Schau' ich mal an. WDO kannst du ohne Probleme 1.000 Euro ausgeben.
Guck mal, wie lange kannst du WoW spielen für 1.000 Euro?
Ganze Weile, paar Jahre.
Ja, sehe ich auch so. Abo-Modell ist das Beste.
Bei MMOs auf jeden Fall.
Und ich glaube, dass auch ein kleineres Studio ein gutes MMO macht.
Also nicht den WoW-Killer, der quasi alles wie WoW macht, bloß besser.
Wie gesagt, das ist vor allem mit einem kleinen Team eh nichts zu machen.
Sondern die halt was finden, was für sie passt.
Und es muss ja auch gar nicht so ultrafine Spieler ansprechen.
Wenn du überlegst, du hast dann, keine Ahnung, fünf Server, jeder Server, 3.000-4.000 Spieler.
Das ist dann schon relativ viel.
Und mit einem Abo-Modell ist das ordentlich.
Da kommt ein Entwickler gut mit hin, weitere Konten für zu entwickeln.
Solange halt keine hunderttausende Millionen sonst was braucht,
für neue Raids und Gedöns und Voice-Acting und Animieren und zig neue Gebiete.
Muss halt passen.
Ja, ab und zu mal ein Addon.
Einmal im Jahr, alle zwei Jahre.
Das Spiel sinnvoll erweitert.
Ich glaube, das kann was werden.
Ob es mit Camelot Unchained was wird, habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Die sind so massiv hinten dran.
Die sind so übertrieben hinten dran, dass ich da wirklich meine Zweifel habe, ob das was wird.
Ich würde es mir wünschen.
Das wäre schon geil.
Abo-Modell sperrt oft viele jüngere Spieler aus.
Warum?
Da war gerade auch ein Abo-Modell und ich habe das gespielt.
Also erst kannst du ein Konto haben, heute mit den Eltern zusammen ab.
Was, zwölf?
Ich weiß es nicht.
14 oder was weiß ich.
Außerdem machst du es einfach mit der Kreditkarte am Konto von den Eltern.
Also als wäre das jetzt irgendwie das Problem.
Das habe ich auch gemacht.
Und wenn du in einem In-Game-Shop einkaufen willst, hast du das gleiche.
Sobald es um Kohle geht, hast du überall das gleiche Problem.
Ich glaube, viele Eltern wollen das nicht.
Wenn es die gleichen Eltern sind, die Fortnite-Skins bezahlen, natürlich machen die das.
Klar machen die das.
Kein Ding.
Und man davon abgesehen, es wäre wahrscheinlich auch kein Ultra-Verlust für den MMO, wenn
es nur Leute ab 14 spielen würden.
Ich glaube, das wäre eigentlich auch, oder ab 16.
Ich glaube, das wäre auch kein Ultra-Verlust und da gibt es auch genug Spieler für, wenn
man es halt so auslegt, dass es eben auch funktioniert mit.
Ich habe nicht 3 Millionen Abos.
Kann das Ding mal verrecken jetzt?
Au!
Fischer Mob.
Jetzt abkratzen, please.
Jawoll.
Loot Poggers.
Vorarlskins in 2003.
Ich habe jetzt ja noch über irgendwas als Beispiel genommen.
Elves.
Haben wir alles abgeklappert hier schon?
Passt so aus, eine Schatztour fehlt noch.
Da ist sie doch.
Oh nee, wir haben was vergessen.
Chest Bear, oh nee.
Aber das Spiel ist nett, das zeigt einem an, wo was ist.
Guck, du bist hoch, zeigt es mir an.
Ich war wahrscheinlich einfach oben noch in irgendeinem Raumlicht drin.
Und was sie auch gut gemacht haben, ist, wenn man das Level cleared hat, kann ich einfach
auf die Treppe klicken und beam ich dann runter ins nächste Stockwerk.
Das sind so Quality of Life Sachen, die ich nicht schlimm finde.
Es muss ja, ein Spiel ist ja nicht dadurch schwer oder wird nicht dadurch irgendwie
Langzeit motivieren, dadurch, dass es ätzend ist.
Kann ein Spiel schwer machen und man kann ihm Spieltiefe verleihen, ohne dass man ultra
nervige Dinger einbauen muss.
Haben wir es.
Nächste Etage, oh wir haben Level Up.
Ja, mit Blizzard ist eh vorbei, weil wir es gerade von MMOs hatten, das heißt natürlich,
der MMO auch mit rein, ich glaube Blizzard ist, das ist Geschichte, dass man da irgendwie
gute Sachen erwarten kann.
Früher hat es die Sache, wenn Blizzard ein Game rausgebracht hat, es war eigentlich egal
in welchem Genre, es war halt in der Regel immer geil.
Immer.
Und wenn nicht, haben sie es tatsächlich sogar eingestellt, als sich noch irgendeiner
Warcraft Adventure oder sowas erinnert, wo sie die Story dann ein bisschen in Warcraft 3
recycelt haben.
Aber Blizzard, das ist Geschichte.
Ich meine, überleg mal, welches Spiel von Blizzard früher war wirklich scheiße.
Es gab nicht viel.
Ghosts, genau, Ghosts haben sie auch eingestellt.
Die haben eigentlich immer ein Ding nach dem anderen rausgehauen.
Diablo 1, StarCraft, WarCraft, 1, 2, 3, StarCraft, oh.
Stuhl.
Das habe ich jetzt vergessen.
Diablo, WarCraft, StarCraft, oh, Minecraft, lol.
Diablo 1, 2, 3, lassen wir mal außen vor.
Was, was?
Was klickt du fix?
Hä?
Ich dachte, die Karte ist kaputt oder so.
Ja, und wenn man sich anguckt, danach kam halt, also ich finde so das letzte richtig gute
Blizzard Game, nehmen wir mal, zählen wir mal Overwatch mit, dann war es Overwatch, wobei
sie das halt, finde ich, auch in vielen Belangen leider, leider verkackt haben.
Und wenn man sich den Quartalsbericht von Blizzard anguckt, sieht man auch, dass es
nicht verkackt ist.
Die Spielerzahlen sind ganz schön im Arsch von Overwatch, also erst im Arsch.
Verständlich irgendwo, ja.
Aber ich finde so das richtig letzte gute Spiel, im Geiste von den Spielen, die Blizzard
für mich eigentlich mal ursprünglich gestanden hat, war Wings of Liberty.
Was ja auch für StarCraft 2 ein versprechender Anfang war.
Danach nicht so, weiß nicht.
Also, das Ende der StarCraft 2 Kampagne war echt, naja, ich will euch nicht spoilern,
aber es war jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Also die ganzen Raynor Carrigan Geschichten, wie sie die aufgelöst haben, ey, das hätte
eigentlich schlimmer kaum sein können.
Alter, wie ist mich Stunt?
Das fette Goat.
Goat's Composition.
Oh, das sind Sperrgeister.
Erstelltsgeister.
Kein Nix.
Alles Ups.
Also Blizzard Aktie weiß ich nicht, aber den letzten Quartalsbericht, oder letzten Jahresbericht,
ist vielleicht sogar der Jahresbericht, nee, das ist der Quartalsbericht.
Spielzahlen in Overwatch sind schlecht.
Im Prinzip lebt Blizzard von Vogue nach wie vor.
Zum Teil Hearthstone.
An Overwatch ist das Einzige, was ein bisschen Geld macht, und da weiß ich nicht, wie schön
es gerechnet ist, ehrlich gesagt, die Overwatch League, wobei ich glaube, dass es sehr schön
gerechnet ist letztendlich, weil dann auch im Vorfeld das auf die Kohle reingeflossen
ist.
Oh, ach nee, ich dachte neue Karte.
Kann das sein, dass man anstatt neue Karten drops, wenn man die Karte schon hat, eine
Hule kriegt?
Das wäre natürlich cool.
Die veröffentlichen keine Spielzahlen.
Naja, die müssen in gewisser Weise, sag mal so, sie müssen vielleicht jetzt nicht die
Spielzahlen direkt auf die Zahl veröffentlichen, aber die müssen ja ihren Bericht können
sie ja die Leute nicht anlügen.
Du hast ja das Recht zu erfahren, wie es um das Unternehmen steht, wo du dein Geld drin
investiert hast.
Also das heißt, das Beste, wenn man wissen will, was, auch wenn die Dinge immer ein bisschen
nervig zu lesen sind und im Prinzip 80% wegschmeißen kannst, am besten ist, wenn man sich irgendwelche
Sachen für Aktionäre anguckt, weil das darfst du rein rechtlich gesehen schon nicht schön
rechnen oder drum herum labern, dann hast du Probleme.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Spielerzahlen drinne standen, aber es stand auf jeden Fall
drinne.
Doch, ich glaube zu Overwatch, wir können ja gleich mal gucken, ich glaube zu Overwatch
standen sogar, wenn ich direkt indirekt, wo man sich draus ableiten kann, Spielerzahlen
drinne.
Das kam schon im 8.
November oder so raus, also nur ein bisschen her.
Es steht auf jeden Fall drinne, was das macht und du kannst es dann vergleichen mit dem,
was es, wie es vorher gesehen hat, also sprich, kannst du ja davon ableiten, wenn die im
Jahr vorher quasi 300% mehr Skin verkauft haben, kannst du dir von ausgehen, dass die
Spielerzahlen nicht gerade gestiegen sind.
Und die haben auch ziemlich sicher User drinne stehen.
Wie gesagt, es kam am 8.
November oder so schon raus, müssen wir gleich mal gucken.
Zumindest unabhängig davon, man sieht, dass, und das sieht man auch an bei anderen Läden,
wenn man sich die Sachen für die Aktionäre anguckt, dass da oftmals gar nicht so rosig
läuft und mich wundert es nicht, ich meine, guckt euch das doch mal an.
Erinnert euch da noch an das Diablo-Dibakel da auf der Blizzcon.
Fuck.
Eine Stellsboda.
Ja, und was man auch sehen wird, wenn EA das nächste Mal was veröffentlicht, wird man
auch sehen, dass die Battlefield 5-Verkaufszahlen mega beschissen sind.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wenn man den Spielern im Vorfeld erzählt, wenn es euch nicht gefällt, dann kauft euch
das Spiel nicht und wenn man zu arrogant ist, quasi davon auszugehen, dass die Spieler
das auch machen, muss man sich mal überlegen, dann gehört es einem echt nicht besser.
Erinnert ihr euch noch an das Interview mit dem Typ, mit dem, wie hieß er, Söderberg?
Irgendwie so hieß der Dude doch von DICE, der erzählt hat, dass er, so dieses legendäre
Interview nach dem Motto, er ist auf der richtigen Seite der Geschichte, wenn er seiner Tochter
erzählen kann, sie kann eine Frau in Battlefield spielen und so.
Das war ja das, das ist eines der allerdings.
Und da hat er ja quasi dann, da ist er dann auch das drinnen gefallen, so nach dem Motto,
die Spieler sollen sich das halt einfach nicht kaufen, wer mit unserer Geschichtsvision
nicht zufrieden ist.
Und da haben viele Spieler halt auch gesagt, ich meine, das ist, das ist der Marketing-Failspruch
schlechthin, ja.
Haben, haben, haben Spieler halt gesagt, nö.
Glaub ich halt nicht.
Ja, der ist mittlerweile nicht mehr dabei.
Das stimmt, er ist rausgeflogen.
Aber das war halt schon ein Fail.
Das ändert nichts daran, was aus dem Spiel geworden ist.
Ich, mir persönlich, ich, ich find's ein bisschen lieblos.
Das ist glaub ich die beste Beschreibung für Battlefield 5.
Eben kein ganz gutes Game, aber irgendwie lieblos, ein bisschen das, was die letzten
Jahre viele Battlefield-Games geworden sind.
Mit lieblos, was man, was ich meine, ist, was man im Battlefield auch ganz, ganz gut
sieht, ist, ich mein, woran man zum Beispiel schon direkt sieht, dass Battlefield 5 ziemlich
lieblos ist oder wenig, wenig, ja, Kreativität und ja einfach, ja, ja doch lieblos trifft
es eigentlich ganz gut.
Eingeflossen ist, guckt euch mal das Menü an.
Ich mein, sieht für euch das Battlefield 5-Menü irgendwie nach einem Zweite-Welt-Krieg-Spiel
aus?
Das sieht aus wie ein Battlefront 2-Menü.
Das sieht aus wie ein Battlefront 2-Menü für einen Zweiten-Welt-Krieg-Spiel.
Wenn überhaupt.
Das Menü sieht null nach Zweiten-Welt-Krieg aus.
Und vom Content, der drinne ist, reden wir mal gar nicht.
Aber zumindest zu Release schlecht war und anstannen lassen.
Und die hatten nicht mal eine Trainings-Range am Anfang drin.
Wenn ihr in das Hauptmenü gegangen bist von Battlefield 5 bei Release und wollt es auf
den Übungsplatz, um Sachen auszuprobieren, stande bei der, bei der Firing-Range, bei
der Trainings-Range, Practice-Range, stande Coming Soon.
Lol.
Coming Soon, das ist immer eine Trainings-Range drinne.
Practice-Range, Coming Soon.
Ich meine, hallo.
Das kann es eh nicht sein.
Au.
Erstmal, erstmal das Ding da hinten in der Ecke baschen, falls sie hinkommen.
Übrigens das Spiel ist auch Early Access und es funktioniert einfach.
Au.
Bam.
Oh.
Gut.
Jetzt haben wir ausgewonnen.
Nächste Gold-Splashen.
So, und, ähm, ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen, ja, darf ich mich moveen?
Ich hab letztens ein Video, weil wir es gerade von Blizzard hatten, ich hab letztens ein
Video gesehen über den Abgang vom ehemaligen Blizzard-Chef und einer der, wie gesagt, Gerüchte,
gerüchtige Gerüchte, ja, einer der Hauptgründe dafür soll wohl gewesen sein, dass er gesagt
hat, äh, Overwatch ist nicht eSport ready.
Was natürlich Activision überhaupt nicht gefallen hat, ja.
Fanden die nicht geil.
Ungeblich haben wir hier unten, kann da da unten noch was sein, haben wir da was vergessen?
Ah, ein Fass.
Ein Fass hab ich noch vergessen.
Okay, das Fass müssen wir jetzt auch noch kaputt machen.
Und man sieht es ja auch so ein bisschen daran, dass es mit Blizzard vorbei ist.
Habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass Hots eingestellt, naja, ey, okay, eingestellt ist das falsche
Wort, aber habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass Hots mehr oder weniger gecancelt ist?
Heroes of the Storm.
Eingestellt ist das falsche Wort.
Also sagen wir mal, dass Heroes of the Storm jetzt auf Sparflamme läuft.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Als ob das jemand spielt, ja, das ist auch ein Teil davon.
Haha, da wollten sie lustig sein.
Au.
Overwatch ist mittlerweile so das richtige View-Only-Game.
Es gucken recht viele, aber es spielt keiner mehr.
Das ist komisch, ey.
Das ist, normalerweise ist das immer umgedreht.
Es spielen viele und es interessieren sich davon nicht alle für E-Sport oder so, aber
Overwatch, Overwatch, ey, was ist denn hier auf dem Bildschirm gerade los?
Overwatch ist wirklich View-Only.
Ein bisschen wie Pearl, das ist Ride-Only.
Overwatch ist View-Only.
Ich geh erstmal nach oben.
Oh man, ey, der Stun ist fies.
Einmal meine Rüstung ist OP, die Herzen droppt, wenn ich Damage krieg.
Das ist sehr nice.
Oh, oh, hab ich keinen Heal mehr?
Ich hab keinen Heal mehr.
Ups, glaub ich muss mal in die Stadt.
Wo ist weg?
Ist der's?
Okay, jetzt lass ich erstmal meinen...
Nein.
Ich möchte...
Hat die mir grad das aufgefüllt umsonst?
Level Up?
So, wir können uns noch ne Karte kaufen.
Karten-Slot.
Wir kaufen uns noch nen Karten-Slot, danach reicht das.
Für mehr hab ich gar keinen Mana dann.
Oh, und Karten identifizieren, ja sehr nice.
GIF.
Was haben wir denn da Schönes?
Town-Portal.
Hab ich schon.
Die Level sind aber so klein, dass man das kaum braucht.
Das ist useless.
Ich mein, das ist ganz nett, dass das Ding explodiert, wenn ich's benutze, aber...
10% Chance und außerdem hab ich die andere schon geupgraded, das...
sind die so wirklich.
Das holen wir erst nach dem Level Up.
Hier weiter geht's.
Hast du schön Weihnachten, Jor?
War ganz gut.
Ach, das ist ein Boss, deswegen gibt's hier so viel Damage.
Komm schon, Goats.
Die Goats.
Oh nee, ich bin gefriest.
Muss die Goats bashen.
Nicht die Goats, die... die Ghosts.
Goats muss ich auch bashen.
Goats.
Bam.
Hier neben dem Brunnen ist nice, da kann ich mich gleich heilen.
Was haben die da eigentlich für ne Range?
Das ist ja wirklich überquert über die ganze Map.
Das Ding ist immun.
So schnell, dass noch Goats dranhängen hat.
Jetzt aber.
Die letzte... letzte Goat.
Passiert echt nicht, wie viel das wird.
Nie immun.
Warum bist du immun?
Du darfst nicht immun sein.
Warum genau ist das Viech immun?
Ah, weil es ein Schild hat.
Bam.
Host kam rein?
Echt?
Nice Host.
Oh, huge Host.
Da hab ich den gehostet.
Nice, Dankeschön.
Apostel.
Nice.
Future Host.
Ah, das ist so Condemn Inquisitor Diablo 3-mäßig.
Good Host.
Ich bin grad stehen geblieben wegen MMOs.
Ja, genau, stimmt.
Habt ihr das...
Nee, es hat schon gefragt, ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt mit Heroes of the Storm, auch Sparflamme
und sowas.
Ich mein, einer der Sachen ist natürlich, dass Heroes of the Storm wahrscheinlich nicht
das erfüllt hat, was sich da Blizzard drunter erhofft hat, aber ich mein, man hat ja auch
aktiv dafür gesorgt, dass es irgendwie in die Hose geht, ne?
Wenn man sich anguckt, dass sie quasi Heroes of the Storm, diese Heroes of the Storm League
war ja so ein bisschen der erste Versuch von so einer eigenen eSport-Liga von Blizzard,
wo sie halt alle Fäden in der Hand haben und wenn du halt dafür sorgst, dass es ja quasi
kaum Trittanbieter gibt, so ein bisschen wie in Overwatch, was auch der Fail von Overwatch
letztendlich ist, eSport-technisch.
Warum ich denke, dass es eben auch so zu einem View-Only-Game geworden ist, wie jetzt, ist,
dass es keine Trittanbieter-Tournaments gibt.
Ich mein, es gibt den Overwatch, es gibt Overwatch League und es gibt nichts.
Es gibt Contenders, aber ich mein, Contenders wird ja nicht mal von Blizzard richtig beworben.
Wenn man sich anguckt, Contenders, lass dich mal auf der Zunge zeigen, Contenders, Korea
hatte das letzte Mal, glaub ich, 3000 Zuschauer.
Apex, Korea hatte irgendwie was? 25.000?
Warum das dann bei Riot klappt?
Naja, es funktioniert ja auch.
Es funktioniert ja auch bei Overwatch League, funktioniert ja.
Ich weiß, mit LoL kenne ich mich zu wenig aus, dass ich da sagen könnte, wie es mit Tier
2, 3 Szenen aussieht.
In Overwatch sind die nicht existent.
Es gibt zwar Contenders, aber Contenders ist, wie gesagt, es ist halt vorhanden.
Wirklich, ist wirklich dafür interessiert, tut sich keiner.
Und...
A goat bashing.
Und du hast dann auch keine Trittanbieter, die irgendwas machen.
Das heißt, aktuell ist es in Overwatch wirklich Overwatch League oder nichts im Endeffekt.
Und ob das für die Dauer, für die Gesundheit des Games jetzt zuträglich ist, habe ich
so meine Zweifel.
Zumal es ja jetzt schon ziemlich view-only ist.
Die Spielzahlen sind unten.
Und das, obwohl ich im Kern finde, ist Overwatch von neuen Games, die rausgekommen sind, eines
der besten der letzten Jahre schlechthin.
Das ist eigentlich so das letzte geile Game von Blizzard.
Seit langer Zeit mal wieder.
Und wie gesagt, Gerüchten zufolge war es ja auch so, dass der ehemalige Blizzard-Chef
mit, wie gesagt, Gerüchte, Gerüchte, seinen Posten mit dafür räumen musste.
Ich meine, er ist da sicher zurückgezogen geablernd.
Weil er gesagt hat, dass Overwatch nicht ready ist und es hat aktivistisch ordentlich
gefallen.
Und man sieht das ja auch schon ein bisschen daran, dass das eigentlich seit, ich weiß,
wir sind jetzt ein bisschen weit gekommen von MMOs letztendlich zu Overwatch, aber
mein, was soll ich sonst erzählen, während ich hier hack'n'slayer, ne?
Dass so essentielle Sachen wie ein Observer-Modus, äh, nicht Observer, ähm, Replay-Modus fehlen
und sowas in der Richtung.
Ich meine, für ein Game, was sich quasi auf die Fahne geschrieben hat, das sind der
nächste geile E-Sport-Shit zu werden, dann hat man keinen Spectator.
Äh, kein, kein...
Yes.
Da ging's jetzt auch gerade durch.
Spectator hat man keinen Replay-Modus.
Kann's eigentlich nicht sein.
Ein Replay-Modus ist, ähm, essentiell.
Das ist, das ist, das ist einfach Pflicht.
Das braucht jedes Game, was sich irgendwie ein bisschen competitive auf die Fahne geschrieben
hat, braucht einen Replay-Modus.
Und ich hab's selten von so vielen Spielern, die das Spiel wirklich ernsthaft spielen,
Semi-Pros und auch Pros, ähm, gehört, wie in Overwatch, dass sie das Spiel hassen.
Das, das hab ich noch mit noch keinem anderen Game gehört.
So viele Pros sagen das auch auf ihren Streams, ähm, und von ein paar Semi-Pros hab ich's
auch selbst gehört.
Sie hassen das Game.
Das, das, das hast du bei, das hast du bei fast nichts irgendwie.
Ja?
Ich mein, klar, wenn du ein Spiel 30.000 Stunden grindest, dann ist das jetzt nicht,
dann ist das schon mehr Arbeit als, als jetzt, ähm, purer Spaß, ja?
Aber es ist schon ein Unterschied dazwischen, ob du ein Spiel echt nicht machst und eigentlich
nur für, ja, für deinen Vertrag spielst.
Oder ob du das Spiel magst.
Und nachdem es auch keine ordentliche Tier 2 und 3 und nach, wo Nachwuchs sonst was Szene
gibt in Overwatch, halt, ja?
Ich finde, es irgendwie nicht so, hat sich, erstens auf jeden Fall nicht so entwickelt,
wie ich's mir gehofft hätte von Overwatch.
Ihr wisst ja, ich war übelst, übelst begeistert von Overwatch und auch übel, und hab so viele
Stunden reingesteckt, auch.
Ja, war da richtig, wie, wie nennt man so, in, involved und engaged und alles, ja?
Damals noch mit eigenem Team und zwar, das war auch geil, ja?
Und Overwatch ist auch ein Spiel, was eigentlich so richtig Bock macht im Team.
Ja.
Geiststelzer.
Ich brauch unbedingt was gegen, gegen Vereisungskram, ey.
Muss ich mal gucken, was es da so gibt, weil das, die, die Monster, die machen mich übelst
fertig.
Weil die Axt bringt mir schon mal was, dass ich mehr Damage mach.
Ich versteh das Blizzard auf die Sports-Schiene, klar.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Haben sie die falschen Leute oder so dafür, keine Ahnung.
Ich mein, es gibt kein, es gibt kein Nachwuchs in Overwatch so richtig.
Es gibt keine Tier-2-Szene und nichts.
Es gibt Overwatch-League.
Und vor allem will Blizzard ja auch gar nicht unbedingt mal rein, weil E-Sport jetzt der
heiße Shit ist und das auch.
Sondern weil sie halt komplett das Sagen haben wollen.
Man muss sich ja nur mal angucken, wie die Verhältnisse sind, wem die League-Teams so
gehören.
Die Overwatch-League-Teams sind, im Endeffekt ist es ja nicht so, dass jetzt irgendjemand
gesagt hätte, hey, wir wollen jetzt London Spitfire machen oder wir wollen jetzt, keine
Ahnung, die und die Sache machen oder wie heißt, Dallas Fuel, das ist ja am Endeffekt
Envious.
Wenn es danach gegangen wäre, hätte Hestro garantiert seinen Namen behalten, anstatt sich
Dallas Fuel zu nennen.
Die Namen gehören ja letztendlich, ich weiß nicht, ob die Namen auf ein paar Plier-Blizzards
gehören, aber manche Teams gehören ja sogar direkt Blizzard.
Man muss es sich mal vorstellen.
Manche Overwatch-Teams gehören direkt Blizzard.
Das ist halt, da ist halt auch mehr Schein als sein dabei.
Und das Overwatch League so ziemlich das Einzige ist, was noch Kohle macht, in puncto Overwatch,
sieht man halt daran, also wie gesagt, guckt euch den letzten Quartalsbericht an und kann
nur damit zusammenhängen, dass es kaum noch einer spielt.
Und ich hätte es mir echt gewünscht, dass Overwatch der nächste Esports-Hit wird, dass
das richtig langzeitgeile, quasi das neue, nennen wir es mal, das neue CSGO oder sowas
wird.
Ich hätte mir das echt gewünscht und halt auch dementsprechend mit der passenden Entwicklung
für das Game.
Aber das gab es leider nicht.
Wo retten das Viech noch hin?
Hallo?
Goat.
Goat, komm mal wieder.
Na ja, genug, genug Overwatch.
Falls ihr irgendwas im Chat gefragt habt und ich hab es halt gesehen, schreibt es, schreibt
es nochmal.
Ich bin konzentriert hier auf Essen, zwei Gelaber und zwei, dass ich nicht gekillt werde.
Warum, warum ist das Immun?
Ah, deswegen.
Goat.
Stun.
Wollen wir uns die Berichte nicht zusammen antworten, können wir machen.
Was du spielst, das ist Book of Demons.
Das ist quasi Diablo 1 auf Schienen.
Da sieht man schon daran, ja, das ist auch wieder so ein Punkt, weil einer gerade geschrieben
hat.
Da sieht man auch schon, dass Overwatch gar nicht ready war.
Es gibt oder gibt immer noch kein Replay-Modus.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab mal gelesen, dass ergeblich auf dem PTR sowas ist.
Es gab am Anfang, am Anfang genau, am Anfang gab es noch nicht mal einen ordentlichen Spectator-Modus.
Oh, ich hab was vergessen.
Oh, oh, Moment, wir können noch nicht runter, ich hab hier, da, da muss ich hin.
Es gab ja noch nicht mal einen richtig funktionierenden ordentlichen Spectator-Modus am Anfang.
Ja, und da muss wohl der ehemalige Blizzard-Chef gesagt haben, ja, das Game ist noch nicht
ready.
Das ist auf mich allzu viel Gegenliebe gestoßen.
Ich mein, Overwatch ranked ist auch somit die frustrierendste und toxischste Erfahrung,
die man, die man so haben kann, ja.
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Ich hab's vor noch keinem Spiel gehört und das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt nicht ausgedacht,
ja.
Ich hab es bisher nur in Overwatch gehört, dass jemand zu mir gesagt hat, er hat Angst,
ranked zu spielen.
Angst.
Wir reden jetzt nicht von, oh nee, ich spiele nicht gerne ranked, oh nee, ich spiele nicht
gerne competitive, sondern ich hab wirklich, ich kenne ein paar Leute, die haben wirklich
gesagt, sie haben Angst davor, Overwatch ranked zu spielen.
Also, das kannst du ja nur echt nicht sein, oder?
Dass man Angst vor, dass man bei einem Spiel Angst haben muss.
Was hab ich denn jetzt hier noch vergessen auf dem Level?
Ryan.
Wo ist das denn?
Warum?
Ah, da.
Ah, da leuchtet es ja auch und die andere Barrel ist unten.
Overwatch ranked ist halt ganz schlimm.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht Angst, seinen Rang zu verlieren.
Das nicht.
Angst zu spielen.
Wegen dem Spiel, vor allem wahrscheinlich wegen den Mitspielern, wegen dem Voice Chat,
wegen dem Gefühl, man kann nichts bewirken.
Wirklich Angst vorm Spielen.
Von Hard, oder?
Nee, oh jetzt bin ich zu weit gerannt.
Sucht auf Reddit, gibt es genug, die sich dazu auch ausgelassen haben.
Ich übertreib mich.
Guck, guck, guck, sogar auf Reddit gibt es genug.
Wirklich Leute schreiben, sie haben Angst davor, es zu spielen.
Das deckt sich mit dem, was ich von ein paar Leuten gehört hab, die ich persönlich kenne.
Das ist halt...
Hard.
Ich kann es auch irgendwo verstehen.
Es gibt kaum ein Game, was mehr an den Nerven zieht als Overwatch ranked.
Ach, da ist die Barrel.
Und das ist halt echt ein bisschen problematisch.
Ich glaube, es liegt auch ein bisschen mit daran, dass ein Trend, den Blizzard, finde
ich, mit so ein bisschen schon mit StarCraft 2 angefangen hat, wobei das ganz in Anklang
StarCraft 2 ist immer noch eigentlich rein skillbasiertes Game.
Vor allem One on One ist natürlich eine Sache, die kannst du auch super ranken.
Die sich dann besonders offensichtlich in Heroes of the Storm fortgesetzt hat, ist die
Ansicht, dass individuelles Play hinter Comeback-Möglichkeiten und hinter Teamstärke anstehen muss.
Ich hab LOL nicht genug gespielt und ich hab auch Dota nicht gespielt, aber ich glaube,
jeder von uns kennt ein paar Highlight-Videos, sei es von Dota oder von LOL.
Und da hast du halt teilweise Plays drinnen, die sogar ich als Voll-Mobar-Dota-LOL-Noob
erkenne, dass die absolut genial gespielt sind.
Dass du da teilweise Leute hast, die Dinger predigten, die jetzt passieren und dann passieren
und er schon den Spell vorher gemacht hat und er quasi auf dem richtigen Pixel ankommt,
weil das eingetreten ist, was er sich vor drei Sekunden überleset.
Übelsgeiles Zeug und dabei macht er noch irgendwie perfektes pixelgenaues Movement,
dass seine Waffe in der Mitte ist, obwohl die normalerweise Bögen fliegt.
Dann denk ich mir auch so, Alter, da merkte das der Typ, keine Ahnung, sein halbes Leben LOL gekreinert hat.
Und solche Plays gibt's halt.
Hotz nicht.
Kann ich sagen, wie gesagt, meine Erfahrungen von dem Game hält sich auch in Grenzen.
Kann ich sagen, dass es einfach ist oder so.
Und Overwatch ist auch nicht einfach in dem Sinn.
Aber es gibt halt ganz wenige Möglichkeiten, so die Killer-Plays zu machen.
Wenn du in Overwatch ein Team hast...
Oh, was ist das für ein Fisch?
Alter, geh weg.
Mist dich.
Jumpsort sich einer ab.
Wenn du in Overwatch, und ich vermute mal in Hotz, ist es genauso.
Wenn du da ein Team hast, sagen wir mal, du hast...
Alter, geh weg.
Sagen wir mal, du hast ein Team mit drei ganz guten Spielern,
einem wirklich herausragend kreativen, guten Spieler, der auch die Rolle spielen darf, die er gut kann,
und zwei ganz guten.
Dann verlierst du wahrscheinlich gegen ein Team, wo alle überdurchschnittlich sind.
Obwohl man sagen könnte, dass im Durchschnitt, deswegen ist glaube ich auch der Punkt, warum das Ranksystem nicht richtig funktioniert,
im Durchschnitt beide Teams gleich stark sind.
Aber in Overwatch ist es halt ganz extrem, wenn du eine oder, sagen wir mal, zwei...
Mit zwei Positionen hast du direkt verloren.
Wenn du zwei Positionen hast, wo die Leute Klasse nicht können,
oder halt die Positionen spielen, die sie nicht wollen, oder keinen Bock haben,
oder vielleicht gerade ein bisschen was verkacken, ist Instant-Loss, kannst du kriegen.
Du kannst in Overwatch nur beschränkt was durch individuelles Play leisten.
Also nicht so wie in anderen Games.
In CS übertrieben gesagt, kann einer fünf Leute wegsniden.
Das ist ganz übertrieben, das passiert zwar so von quasi nie, aber kann, ja? Kann.
Das ist eine Sache, die kann in Overwatch in der Form schon mal gehen mit dem Gegnerabwehr.
Das kann mal gar nicht richtig passieren.
Oh, der Gegner da ist glaube ich ein bisschen schwieriger.
Wo ist er? Wo ist er? Wie ist er?
Oh, ein Bra.
Ich geh mal kurz zum Helz.
Das ist glaube ich hauptsächlich auch das, wo die Frustration ist.
Alter, der Gegner, ey.
Gib mir den mal ab.
Au.
Komm, geh, geh kaputt.
Jetzt wird er gebashed.
Destroyed.
Schreckt. Oh, nee.
Jetzt langsam wird das Spiel anstrengend.
Warum kein Twitch Partner? Na ja, weil ich mich immer noch nicht drauf gekümmert hab.
Jetzt aber, jetzt haben wir ihn, ne?
Ey, was hält denn das Viech aus?
Teleport, Stells.
Jetzt aber, komm. Geh down.
Kann man nicht abbrechen?
Oh, die Dodging Skills, guckt's euch an.
Jawoll.
Huge Skills.
So, äh, wir sind irgendwie ziemlich beknackt gelaufen, ne?
Ah nee, hier ist die Treppe. Okay, passt.
Haben wir aufgemacht.
Geh mal nach da oben gucken. Da oben waren wir auch schon. Passt.
Aber, geh mal erstmal hier weiter.
Dein Spiel des Jahres.
Problem ist, ich bin ultravergesslich, nachdem ich ein Spiel durchgespielt hab.
Ich tendiere zu Breath of the Wild. Wobei, war das überhaupt 2018?
War das schon letztes Jahr? Ich glaub, das war schon letztes Jahr.
Oder?
Ey, Mario Odyssey war es, was dieses Jahr so rumging.
Oh, das war nice. Mario Odyssey war nice.
So, da muss ich mal überlegen.
Spiel des Jahres. Oh, hier geht's runter.
Kann auf jeden Fall kein Konsolenspiel gewesen sein, weil Konsole hatte ich bis auf die Switch dieses Jahr quasi gar nicht an.
Gleich mal mal in der Historie gucken.
Aber Mario Odyssey schon auf jeden Fall mit oben dabei.
Es gibt eh noch relativ viel, was ich nachholen muss. Zum Beispiel God of War muss ich noch nachholen.
Spiel. So, eine Sache haben wir ver...
To do on this level. Oh, ich hab 58 Gold nicht eingesammelt.
58. Ah, liegt doch da unten irgendwo.
Also was definitiv schon mal nicht mein Game des Jahres ist Battlefield 5 und Fallout 76.
Erst mal überlegen.
Red Dead Redemption 2 ist nicht, wie gesagt, ich bin kein großer Open-World-Fan, das heißt das auch nicht.
Tendiere zu Mario Odyssey. Oder war das schon letztes Jahr?
Ja, das kam auch letztes Jahr raus.
Ja, dann gibt's dieses Jahr echt nicht so viel, was in Frage kommt.
Ah.
Ich denke, aus 5, 4 ist es garantiert auch.
Also wo ich noch nicht viel gespielt habe bis jetzt, wo ich nur die ersten paar Sachen gespielt habe, wo ich nur ein paar Stunden bisher gespielt habe,
wo ich auch ein bisschen so late bin, ist Kingdom Come Deliverance.
Einfach weil es eines der wenigen Spiele ist, wo das Mittelalter irgendwie nach Mittelalter sich anfühlt.
Was ist mein Spiel des Jahres?
Das ist echt schwierig.
Ja.
Was gab's denn dieses Jahr geiles? God of War hab ich nicht gespielt.
Red Dead Redemption bin ich kein Open-World-Fan, hab ich auch nicht gespielt.
Was gab's denn da noch alles?
Das kann man gucken.
Monster Hunter World, nee. Fallout, nee.
Assassin's Creed Odyssey hab ich auch nicht gespielt.
Smash ist auch nicht meins gewesen.
Es war Tomb Raider, aber auch nicht.
Es ist wirklich schwierig, ey, dieses Jahr mich für was zu entscheiden.
Das müsste ich erst mal gespielt haben.
Ich kann es hier echt nicht sagen gerade.
Oh, wir haben's geschafft.
Wir sind durch.
Ja, Shinobus.
Das war nice.
Da bin ich immer noch nicht ganz durch, aber das ist ein cooles Game gewesen.
Das hat mir wirklich Spaß gemacht.
Das war ein super Spiel.
Das ist auch so ein Game.
Was muss das sein?
Es sieht aus wie Sonic oder?
So tue ich es auch, das soll nix sein.
Sonic!
Ah, wir visiten mal Thor.
Nein, so, äh, Identify-Card.
Nein, nicht Black Ops 4.
Sehr nice.
Was muss ich equipen?
Das ist Life Rack.
Life Rack brauch ich unbedingt.
GIF.
Bam.
Und gleich Upgrade.
Kann ich Upgrade?
Ja, Upgrade.
So, ich muss jetzt mal kurz Steam pumpen.
Äh, Games.
Kann man, kann man Steam irgendwie ordentlich sortieren nach Zeit oder so?
Jo.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall Kandidat für mein Spiel des Jahres.
Aber Steam hält sich echt den Grenzen.
Das war auch schon, ist auch schon länger her.
Wirklich.
Nicht so wirklich.
Aber Pathfinder war echt nice.
Das hat mir gut gefallen.
Oder gefällt mir immer, ich bin ja immer noch nicht ganz durch.
Die Updaters erweitern, das war auch so ein Game.
Wo sich irgendwie alle Welten drauf gestürzt hatten.
Die einen meinten, oh nee, das ist viel zu schwer.
Und ähm, wie Iswelford 3.
Also was ich bisher von gesehen hab, echt ganz nice.
Upgrades.
Shield.
Shield Upgrade auf das.
Kann ich nicht irgendwie, was brauche ich denn, um, um das Amulett abzucraden?
Leute, ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo spielen, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Was ist denn da jetzt?
also wollen von dreimal ganz okay die sache ist die dass ich das gefühl habe dass es ein
game das haben sie released weil es wie gerade er geschrieben hat im chat weil es potenzial hat
und dass man auch schon dass man auch schon sieht aber ich glaube nicht dass es ein game ist was
jemals fertig wird es ist halt so ein bisschen der fluch von der fluch von er die ex ist irgendwo
hat man was haben wir eben geiles gekriegt eisbombe das ist glaube ich nix für mich
kann man das amulett nicht abkühlen was brauche ich denn für das amulett
einmal live sein was bringt das dann zum abkühlen ist doch hat er für 2 seconds
das wäre schon ganz cool das wäre schon ganz cool
rüstung abkühlen wir auch nice das schild zum abkühlen natürlich das schild zum abkühlen
wäre auch cool weil ich meine wir damit kann man quasi 50 prozent der der feile und
und zeug blocken das wäre schon praktisch und das haben wir auch fatals bericht der spieler
report 2000 feine feiner im november
nicht annual report
so haben die auch ein link dazu die haben sie irgendwie die zusammenfassung drinne ja
genau candy crush saga wieder auf dem ersten platz von vom app store
hier ist jetzt erzählen sie audiens reach wie geil sie sind und was man hier schon sieht
ist erstmal irgendwie kein aber das ist nicht das wo das denn also ich ich weiß dass es
im prinzip schon der gleiche bericht ist weil da auch was von candy crush drinne stand
aber was man was man hier zusammenfassung schon mal ganz gut es ist kaum kaum den wort
von overwatch drinne außer overwatch league ja und damit habe ich jetzt kein bock mich
durchzukämpfen ihr könnt euch das ja wenn euch das angucken wenn es unter dem strich
kommt raus normalerweise stellen sie immer gerne rum was wie wie geil das läuft und
neue zahlen super overwatch unterm strich kommt nichts oder dass es weniger geworden
ist oder dass das einzige was sich lohnt die overwatch league ist richtig patrick genau
und da stehen ja auch die zahlen zu den einzelnen sachen drinne
das da ja das ist die seite genau da ist auch der presse da ist auch die die die presse
die die der konferenz call wo sie das dann irgendwie erklärt haben mit drinne ja das
da ist es halte wie lange ich mags mittlerweile kennen wie macht es ja auch schon eine weile
ja so also wie gesagt wenn sich das irgendwann durch angucken will und wer feststellen will
dass candy crush sage anscheinend immer noch alle rekorde knackt warum auch immer man
weiß nicht so genau es gibt sachen die muss man nicht verstehen black ops 4 ist auch super
erfolgreich und natürlich wo auch ganz besonders toll dessen die feiern sie sich auch übelst
ein ab aber man sieht schon zu overwatch steht da relativ wenig drin steht drinne dass die
es steht im prinzip nicht so overwatch steht immer nur overwatch liegt overwatch liegt
player investment das ist schon ein monat her wo ich mir das angeguckt habe oder wann
es raus ja über den monat handy rush sage das ist wie es aussieht dann fürs vierte
total dieses angepresandt bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
das ist das richtige dokument das hier meine ich auf jeden fall das da hier investor activision
kommen wo irgendwie overwatch da unten drunter finden no revenues overwatch liegt genau hier
ist die blizzard falte da könnt ihr euch ja durchkämpfen wenn es euch interessiert es
aber mal ganz interessant zumindest grob drüber zu gucken das mal letzten die zwei gespielt
die beta gespielt haben die beta haben wir ganz kurz ein bisschen gespielt mal so eine
halbe stunde oder so aber also nee habe ich nicht in dem sinn eigentlich
hier was brauche ich noch mal genau das amulett so ab live man konnte doch irgendwie karten
kräft live brauchen wir
ach nee man kann man kann live und dings zudem ach nee so rum und für das amulett brauche
ich was zweimal live nee das ist mir zu teuer also haben wir keine gar keine korsagen probleme
hier weiter zu kommen ihr preises mana ja holen wir uns mal unsere preises ab oder
mal kommen wir machen noch mal ganz weiter hier very small small big huge big auswitsch
wird schwieriger also paratrooper mehr hält es auf jeden fall gut für overwatch spodas
sind es gut gegen spodas ich dachte mal dass er das dann tut jetzt wollte es aber wissen
er was geht jetzt hier auf dem bildschirm abgraden alter so nicht mehr normal kann das
sein dass kein leben dass ich ey was ist hier los gerade ich habe stein auf den kopf gekriegt
ok ein paar movement abilities wäre nicht schlecht es wird langsam richtig anstrengend
und wie kann ich überhaupt brennen wenn ich im feuer wie kann ich vereist sein wenn ich
im feuer stehe fack alter jetzt wird es aber echt anstrengend
ist die stammmechanik ganz leise jetzt kann ich den typ attack immer noch nicht auf lauf
ich muss unbedingt diesen span mitnehmen gegen eis
auf und stell
sporn
hier geblieben
ok erster down jetzt wollen sie es aber echt wissen
es ist mega immer so flach meine karts werden locker gibt es da charge oh das ist gut das
bramer
besser movement abilities brauche ich auf jeden fall
ja gut was läuft da grünes im weg rum
kommt das auf einmal her aber vorher nicht da
mein geiler meister spoda boss ne scorpion boss
das gefällt dem sie war ja jetzt habe ich mich gefühlt irgendwie wie lang bin ich schon
zwei stunden oder so irgendwie über mmo overwatch und alles mögliche ausgelassen gibt es noch
irgendwas
so wenn ich mich auslassen könnte was ich so einfällt
und recommend
Oh, Mei am Start hier, Ice Walls.
Okay, wo haben, wo hat er noch was hier und da?
Und danach wird das Skorpion gebasht.
Wo ist er?
Ist das Skorpion?
Da!
Baschen!
Die ist einfach kaputt gehn.
Aha, richtig Richtung gechargt.
Jetzt aber, jetzt geht er dauernd.
Wo war noch nicht?
Jetzt wird jetzt aber langsam anstrengend.
Aber dann kann ich gleich mal dieses Random Box in der Stadt aufmachen.
Da gibts noch mehr Loot.
Massive Loot gibts da.
Loot-Massive.
In jedem anderen RPG ist Feuer gegen Spinnen gut.
Hier haben sie sich überlegt, nein, am besten gegen Spinnen ist Gift.
Voll intuitiv, ja.
Wow, falsche Richtung.
Sollte es überhaupt nicht dahin chargen.
Aber es hält die 144 FPS.
Ich brauche das bessere Schild, ich upgraden danach das Schild.
Dann kannst du den ganzen Mist nämlich blocken.
Kannst du nicht einstellen, dass die Zuschauer Einfluss auf das Spiel haben?
Ähm, selbst wenn, ist das glaube ich keine so gute Idee.
Ich meine, wer kennt eh nichts, den, beziehungsweise gibt es eigentlich den Twitch Chat, der damit nichts komisches anstellen würde, ne, oder?
Begibt sich niemals in die Hände vom Twitch Chat.
Sollte sowas gleich hier clear?
Nein, mache ich nicht.
Zum Glück macht Feuer Damage nicht viel Damage.
War alles?
Wenn man das upgradet, ist bestimmt die Charge Reichweite.
Ändert sich bestimmt.
Ah, guck mal, wenn man bei Geister den Spell abbricht.
Dann explodieren sie.
War das nur Zufall?
Es gibt keinen Platz hier.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was wir aus dem Game machen, wenn es aus dem Early Access rauskommt.
Bei dem habe ich irgendwie den Eindruck, dass das was werden könnte.
Ich glaube Overwatch liegt uns demnächst wieder los, genau.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie die Zuschauer zahlen werden diesmal.
Ich würde ja gerne ein eigenes MMO machen, ne.
Wenn ich die Kohle dazu hätte.
Ich weiß, muss ich mehr YouTube Videos machen, easy.
Also ich bräuchte die Kohle dafür und ich bräuchte die Leute dafür.
Dann würde ich ein MMO machen, das mir gefällt.
Wahrscheinlich spielt es dann keiner.
Weil sie alle sagen, Max, das Game suckt.
So ein Kack Game.
Kannst du alleine spielen.
Ich würde gerne ein MMO machen, mit allem, also quasi anhand der Erfahrung der letzten 20 Jahre, was mich an MMOs nervt, würde ich ein MMO machen.
Also ohne die Sachen.
Aber das wird nichts.
Das kann man nicht cancelen oder was.
Das anspruchsvollste, was man überhaupt entwickeln kann.
Das Sterne-Aim.
On point.
Man muss so viel gleichzeitig machen.
Und KS, das mache ich ganz durcheinander.
Und die Spodas, die von oben angestellt kommen, machen das auch nicht besser.
Und Schlüsse.
RPG Maker.
Das ist ein RPG Maker MMO.
Das hat der Welt noch gefehlt.
Hat ein RPG Maker überhaupt Netzwerkfunktion?
Ein RPG Maker MMO, jawoll.
Darauf hat die Welt gewartet.
I go to the moon ist auch ein RPG Maker Game, aber das begeistert auch technisch nicht.
Was habe ich gemacht?
Warum kriege ich so geiles Zeug?
Nichts dagegen, aber Poggers Loot.
RPG Maker steht für mich für ganz viele ganz schlechte Steam-Games im Weep-Style.
Spodas.
Wo eins wie das andere aussieht.
Sag mal.
Wie viele kommen da noch?
Weil wir jetzt einfach stehen und hau um mich.
Easy.
Brauche ich mir noch einen Life-Leech-Ring und dann werden wir...
Streamst du gerade über Unity Media oder Telekom?
Ich stream über Telekom, weil ich bei Unity Media nicht genug Upload habe, bis ich umgestellt habe.
Wie gesagt habe ich schon erzählt, mein Ziel ist ja, dass ich Telekom kicke und Unity Media only.
Mache ich das eigentlich, dass ich manchmal aus Versehen, obwohl ich kein Tab drücke, drücke ich doch manchmal Tab.
Aber auch nicht.
Jetzt noch die Tastatur.
Also wenn das wirklich so funktioniert, wie das der Unity Media Support geschrieben hat, dass ich meinen ordentlichen IPv4 Anschluss behalte, dann wird Telekom gekickt.
Telekom gekickt und Unity Media behalten als einziger Anbieter.
Du kannst deinen IPv4 Anschluss behalten.
Das hat der Typ auf Twitter geschrieben.
Wenn ich ihm gesagt habe, ich mache das nicht, wenn das wegkriegt, dann gehe ich lieber komplett zur Telekom.
Am liebsten hätte ich einen ordentlichen Dual-Stack.
Also so einen Dual-Stack mit vollwertig IPv4 und vollwertig IPv6.
Ich würde mir einen Business Anschluss holen, das Problem ist, dass es da kein Power Upload gibt, wie sie es nennen.
Das heißt, dann würde ich mehr bezahlen und noch nicht mal, hätte ich noch nicht mal ordentlichen Upload und könnte nicht gebrauchen.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen bescheuert.
Ich habe mir sogar ein Business Anschluss geholt, aber der Typ auf Twitter hat geschrieben, dass das geht, ich behalte den.
Ich habe bis jetzt nicht geantwortet mit dem Umstellen, aber wenn das wirklich so ist, dann mache ich es und dann fliegt die Telekom raus.
Golden Keys Replay Quest
Wenn ich einen Schlüssel gefunden habe, kann ich das gleiche noch mal spielen in höherem Schwierigkeitsgrad.
Aber will ich jetzt noch nicht. Was ich cool finde ist, dass man jederzeit in die Stadt kann.
Spoda-Bosses sind so nervig.
Meine Health-Porsche hat sich gelöst, das ist ganz, ganz, ganz schlecht.
BTF
Alter, was ist hier los?
Ein bisschen unfair.
Komm ich auch gar nicht durch.
Ich wollte es aber echt wissen.
Gleich haben wir es, gleich haben wir es alles kaputt.
Ich habe mich gechargt.
Kann er jetzt mal sterben? Nein, man muss sich jetzt verwandeln.
Wie soll ich denn in der Einbahnstraße ausweichen, bitte schön?
Wie soll denn das funktionieren?
Warum ist jetzt wieder voll?
Fertig.
Andere Viecher stellen es da in der Ecke.
Anstrengend, mega anstrengend.
Wo hüpft die Spoda hin?
Oh, das schmeckt nicht über Aua.
Oh, das ist eher ein Spannungsstrem.
Kennt noch jemand irgendwelche geilen Games?
Es sind keine super vollen AAA-Production-Value-Übertriebene-Millionen-Games, die in letzter Zeit rausgekommen sind.
Irgendwelche neuesten Games, die man nicht so kennt, aber mal gespielt haben sollte, die rausgekommen sind in letzter Zeit.
Was macht das denn?
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Ich werde hier laufend damaged.
World War 3, das habe ich ja schon.
Das habe ich schon und das habe ich auch ein bisschen gespielt, nicht so viel.
Das ist halt noch ziemlich unfertig.
Irgendwas, was man auch gut spielen kann. Am besten halt irgendwas, was fertig ist.
Ja, der Twitter-Support von Unity Media, generell der Social Media-Support ist der beste.
Sogar von der Barm als AJ am Start.
Aber auch der Social Media-Support von Unity Media und der Telekom und so.
Besser als bei der Hotline-Anrufen auf jeden Fall.
Übrigens, es sind nur noch 3 Tage oder so oder 4 Tage bis Ende 2018.
Und ihr wisst ja, Ende 2018 hat der Regierungssprecher gesagt, haben wir flächendeckend für jeden Haushalt 50 MBit in Deutschland.
Aber wir müssen jetzt schon in Gigabit denken.
Also, das heißt, wenn ihr noch keine 50 MBit habt, dann sind das einfach komplette Fake-News von eurem Provider.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Ihr habt 50 MBit.
Aber die Halskette ist echt praktisch.
Ich habe auch volle Leben.
Oh, Secret Card.
Oh, was ist das?
Nettes Boder.
Oh!
Darkness Sire of Might and Magic ist das einzige Game, wo Spinnen eklig waren für mich.
In allen anderen Games.
In welchem Game fandet ihr Spinnen eklig?
Normalerweise alle, die in RL auch keine Spinnen abkönnen.
Gibt es irgendwelche Games, wo ihr Spinnen eklig umgesetzt fandet?
Ich setze die dann darauf.
Also bei mir plus Darkness Sire.
Das ist das einzige Game, wo ich Spinnen eklig fand.
Jetzt juckt mich, juckt mich Onscreen-Spinnen nicht.
Immer noch nicht down.
Jetzt aber down.
Ich finde, ihr habt das in dem Game echt ganz gut gemacht zur Interaktion mit den Gegnern.
Man kann Spells cancelen, wenn man draufklickt.
Das ist wirklich ganz cool gemacht.
Ja, nach dem Dungeon holen wir uns die Belohnung aus dem Kessel in der Stadt.
Gibt fettes Loot.
Erste Future Loot gibt es.
Er ist boders.
Weg.
Fisch, Spinn, Sonne, du hast wahrscheinlich kein Geld mehr da.
Wobei ich sagen muss, das Game hat allgemein einen coolen Sound, finde ich.
Also, so das Schild treffen, das fühlt sich gut an.
Auch so das Klicken vor den Fässern und so.
Das ist eh so eine Kunst für sich, so die Soundauswahl für Games.
Bin ich froh, dass es in echt keine selbst heilenden Spinnen gibt.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Ihr habt eine fette Spinne an der Wand sitzen.
Ihr haut drauf, auf einmal sind zwei Spinnen draus geworden.
Ihr macht die Spinne kaputt, dann wieder zwei draus.
Jedes Mal, wenn ihr die Spinne aufmultipliziert, die sich.
Das wäre echt ganz schön.
Da würde ich Zustände kriegen.
Spinnenfork in echt.
Was ist jetzt los?
Die Spodas.
Und ich stehe mitten drinnen.
Ich charge mal weg.
Aber das ist gut, er eskept.
Zwei oder drei Stunden die Spodas zu kehren.
Erst mal Haus niederbrennen, weil Spinnen drin sind.
Am schlimmsten sind Spinnen, die man einmal gesehen hat.
Und dann kurz und danach nicht mehr.
Also wenn ihr wisst, dass die da sind.
Aber man nicht weiß wo.
Ihr seht irgendwie die Spinnen an der Wand.
Wollt irgendwie was holen zum platt machen oder zum saugen oder zum sonst was.
Dann kommt die wieder, das ist weg.
Das ist scheiße.
Da muss man suchen.
Ich kann auch nachts halt pennen, richtig?
Weil ich denke, ich krabbe dann irgendwo bei mir.
Ich glaube wir haben es, oder?
Alles down?
Und das noch was.
Oh, mehr Loot.
Ich habe durch diese Amos die Herzen droppt, habe ich fast so etwas wie Life Leech.
Sehr praktisch.
Alles klar, da ja.
Wobei bei mir eher nicht.
Bei mir ist, was Insekten angeht, ist das sehr rein alles.
Weil ich besonders mit Spinnen nicht habe.
Ich habe überall Fliegengitter.
Also nicht einfach nur Fliegengitter davor.
Sondern wirklich so richtig eng anliegende Dinger.
Aber da kommt nichts rein.
Also ich habe ganz selten mal irgendwas im Haus an Insekten und Ungeziefer.
Wobei es ist, die meisten sind mir eigentlich egal.
Spinnen ist das wo ich echt.
So, EL, Wonka esse.
Nein, falscher Knopf.
Wir war es mal so danach.
Oh nee, enrage, Mob.
Sollte ich, ich sollte den mal nicht enrage kloppen.
Wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt, den enrage Mob nicht enrage zu kloppen.
Hätte was, aber wahrscheinlich für mich viel zu taktisch.
Da platzt er.
Ja, Eiskräuter.
So schlimm war es bis jetzt noch nicht.
Also das ekligste Spinnenmäßig war mal so ein fettes Viech aus dem Keller.
Weil, wie gesagt, wir haben das Haus vom Opa geerbt.
Und der hat ja nie was gemacht in der Richtung.
Der Keller war voll aus Spinnen.
Wir gefühlt hatten wir so alle.
Auf einmal bin ich morgens dann aus dem Schlafzimmer.
Bin ich raus ins Bad und dann sah so ein Viech an der Bartentür.
Das war wohl so die letzte Überlebende, wie es aussah.
Was ist mit dem Viech los?
Oh, das ist auch so ein enrage Mob.
Darf ich ein Auto attacken?
Ja, die können mich ruhig einnetzen, das ist ok.
Spinnen, Boss.
Miss, Miss, Miss, Miss, Miss.
Ah, das ist ein Boss.
Boss, der jetzt gerade noch einen Sack gekriegt hat.
Oh, das gibt so fettes Loot nach diesem Run, ich sag's euch.
Das wird nice.
Wisst ihr was ich beeindruckend finde, wenn ich mir so die Games auf Steam angucke?
Eigentlich bin ich zwei Sachen beeindruckend.
Wie man es schafft, so viel Crab zu releasen.
Weil Steam ist im Prinzip voller Shit.
Wirklich, Steam ist 90% Shit, wenn man sich das anguckt.
Aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, was ich beeindruckend finde, dass
die Games, die Langzeit Spaß machen und allgemein Games, die überhaupt Spaß machen,
dass das zum größten Teil mittlerweile nicht mehr die riesen fetten Titel sind.
So war's hier. Ich mein, wer hätte damit gerechnet, dass das was taugt.
Ich würd mal sagen, von gefühlt...
Ich mein, der Trash-Teil von den Spielen auf Steam ist noch höher als der AAA-Trash-Teil, klar.
Aber anteilmäßig sind die meisten AAA-Games mittlerweile so schlecht irgendwie,
dass wenn man wirklich nach Spiel mit Spielspaß sucht, man fast lieber zu kleinen Krams schaut.
Es gibt natürlich immer noch die einen oder anderen guten AAA-Games, keine Frage.
Anteilmäßig sind die immer noch besser als das auf Steam.
Einfach, da steckt ja ein gewisses Interesse dahinter.
Ich mein, guckt euch doch mal so was an. Fallout 76.
Was soll?
Solche Dinger.
Dann wird das meiste auch wieder ausgesaut bis zum Schluss.
Ich mein, Far Cry 1 war geil. Das war wegweisend, auch grafisch.
War damals noch von Crytek.
Dann kam irgendwann noch Far Cry 2. Das war, glaub ich, schon immer von Crytek.
Und das war scheiße.
Da gab's ein paar Jahre nix und irgendwann kommt Far Cry 3 raus und es war geil.
Und danach kam gefühlt jedes Jahr ein neues Far Cry und jedes Mal wurde es ein bisschen schlechter.
Der Enraged-Spider.
Hört mal vor, wo wir gerade dabei waren, den echten Forken-Spider.
So Enraged-Spider wären noch schlimmer.
Ihr haut drauf, auf einmal spawnen die 80 weitere Spider aus ihrem Spider-S.
Und Far Cry 3 war cool. Für die Zeit, wo Far Cry 3 hielt.
Ich finde, Far Cry 3 war an sich auch recht für das, wie es ging, abwechslungsreich gemacht.
Das sind ja mehrere Phasen von dem Game.
Und das war cool.
Ich hab mir schon am Ende von Far Cry 3 gedacht, so jetzt reicht's, aber was kam?
Far Cry 4. Far Cry 4 war schon mal weniger gut.
Ich darf die Enraged-Mops nicht hauen, warum mach ich das denn noch?
Einfach Auto-Attacken, cool ist.
So und danach kam Far Cry Primal, oder?
Ich glaub schon, hab ich das gar nicht gespielt.
Weil es mir nach Far Cry 4 schon aus dem Hals rausgegangen hat.
So und dann kam jetzt Far Cry 5, hab ich auch nicht gespielt und soll auch nicht gut sein.
Man kann eine Sache auch zu Tode produzieren irgendwie.
Du kannst eh die Zahl an Nicht-Serien-Releases gefühl AAA-mäßig an eine Hand abzählen pro Jahr.
Kommt doch fast nix.
Klar, die wollen auf Nummer sicher gehen irgendwie.
Aber da sieht man halt, was passiert, wenn...
Da sieht man halt, was passiert, wenn an den Stellen halt die BWL-Leute hocken und nicht mehr die kreativen Spielentwickler.
Dann läuft's so, aber Blizzard noch nicht so lange, aber mittlerweile halt auch.
Das Blizzard, was wir so kennen von früher, gibt's halt leider nicht mehr.
Was halt echt sackt.
Hat vorhin irgendeiner gefragt, was ich zu Reforge denke.
Ich find das ne gute Sache.
Ich weiss, wenn man sich anschaut, dass Warcraft 3 mehr Zuschauer hatte als Heroes of the Storm.
Also jetzt mal vor den großen Major-Finalen und so abgesehen hatte Warcraft 3 fast...
In letzter Zeit zumindest.
Warcraft 3 hat ja in den letzten zwei Jahren so richtig auf Twitch so ne Renaissance irgendwie erlebt.
Nicht umsonst auch dank Krabby, der irgendwie Warcraft 3 streamt mit 7.500 Zuschauern mittlerweile.
Ich muss mich mal vorstellen, Warcraft 3.
War krass, oder?
Aber da sieht man halt, ein gutes Spiel ist ein gutes Spiel.
Und auch so gerne, dass Blizzard irgendwie vielleicht Zwischenträgen gehabt hätte, das verfällt halt nicht.
Vor allem in China und Russland ist Warcraft 3 halt immer noch dicke dabei.
Und ich mein, der beste aktuellsten Koreaner. Was sonst?
Ich bin der Meinung, gute Sachen kriegt man nur mit ner gesunden Mischung aus beidem hin.
Man braucht Leute, die ein bisschen das Geschäft im Sinn haben.
Weil du kannst nicht ein Team aus, sagen wir mal, Designern, Programmierern, Künstlern quasi da deine Kohle ohne irgendwie Sinn und Verstand verbraten lassen.
Das ist glaub ich auch... Du wirst ein paar Hits landen auf jeden Fall.
Ob die jemals im Budget bleiben, jemals in der Nähe der Zeit fertig, ist fraglich.
Aber man muss da ne gesunde Mischung glaub ich draus finden.
Und die geht halt immer mehr lehnend abhanden mittlerweile.
Ich find so sinnloses BWL-Basching muss man auch nicht machen.
Es gibt schon... Es hat seine Vorteile, wenn manche sagen koordiniert sind.
Aber es muss halt passen einfach.
Man muss keine Sachen machen, nur weil sie in irgendeinem Best Practice Workflow Handbuch oder sowas stehen, wenn es zu dem eigenen Laden nicht passt.
Und noch kann man manche Sachen wie Spielspaß wirklich in BWL-Sachen fassen.
Ich mein ihr wisst doch, wie lange braucht ne Frau um das Kind zu kriegen, um den BWL-Bash ein bisschen voranzutreiben.
Wie lange ist ne Frau in der Regel schwanger?
Ich weiß es ist nicht euer Spezialgebiet, aber vielleicht hat man schon mal was von gehört.
Ein Spezialgebiet ist es ja auch nicht.
Normalerweise brauchst du ja neun Monate für.
Jetzt ist natürlich aus BWL sich die Frage, wie lange brauchen zwei Frauen für ein Kind?
Und aus BWL-Logik brauchen zwei Frauen für ein Kind natürlich 4,5 Monate.
Was sich halt mit der Realität irgendwie nicht deckt.
Oh, oh, oh! Nicht sterben! Alter, nicht sterben!
Und ja, das ist Vorurteil des BWL-Flames, aber vieles was man aussieht, vor allem außer der Spielentwicklung,
drängt sich einem schon so ein bisschen der Gedanke auf, dass da manchmal so Dinge laufen.
So nach dem Motto, ja wie ihr wollt ne PvP-orientiertes Game machen, wir wollen aber PvE.
Ich dachte, das macht das Game doch nicht schlecht, denn wir beauftragen einfach ein weiteres Studio,
eine Multiplayer, einen PvP-Modus für euer Spiel zu entwickeln.
Das ist ja parallel zu euch, das hat überhaupt keine Auswirkung auf das Spiel und das Spiel wird bestimmt besser.
Oder wenn, das ist Spielscheiße.
So ist das halt, wenn an den Positionen halt keine Spiele-Entwickler mehr stehen.
Oder keine Leute, die von Gamestop verstehen.
Die Games halt als Kohle machen verstehen, aber das ist klar, das verstehen sie mit Sicherheit.
Aber das macht halt keine guten Games.
Oh ne, ich bin zu weit weg.
Hast du ja nicht geportet.
Portest du dich einfach.
Ebesibaro.
Ich darf den Spell nicht cancelen für mich.
Jetzt aber verrecken mal, please.
Nein.
Erbock.
Au.
Beast.
Oh.
Und das ist halt auch der Grund für, dass viele AAA-Games nix taugen.
Wenn du halt manche Sachen in dein Spiel einbauen musst.
Weil irgendjemand sagt, aus welchen Gründen auch immer das, was so sein muss.
Wenn du manche Sachen nicht einbauen darfst, weil du damit ja vielleicht den ein oder anderen Candy Crush Spieler verärgern könntest.
Dann ist das für das Game sicherlich auch nicht gut.
Wenn du aus einem 3-Fraktionen-Spiel, das ist immer mein Lieblingsbeispiel davon, aus einem PVP-Spiel für 3 Fraktionen eins machen musst aus 2 Fraktionen.
Und grotten scheiß PvE, dann muss sich keiner wundern aus dem Spiel sagt am Ende.
Aber das war überhaupt nicht abzusehen.
Und was halt so das Resultat daran ist oftmals, dass dann halt das Studio geschlossen wird, obwohl das Studio genau das entwickeln hat, was es entwickeln sollte.
Aber was willst du machen?
Also Spiele in der Spielebranche arbeiten wirds beim besten Willen nicht wollen.
Also weder als Entwickler noch irgendwie als Versammler.
Besten Willen nicht.
Ja Patrick, es gibt einfach zu wenige MMOs oder PVP-Spiele mit 3 Fraktionen.
Das bin ich immer noch der Meinung, das ist das einzige Homeworld-PVP, was ordentlich funktioniert, weil es nicht 2 gegen 2 ist, sondern 1 vs. 1 vs. 1.
Was viel dynamischer ist und besser funktioniert.
Oder kaputt.
Magst keine Enrage Monster hauen, einfach sinnlos dastehen.
Verliert man was, wenn man... Verliert man seine Progression? Nee, du verlierst ein paar Sachen, wenn du stirbst. Ich bin noch nicht gestorben, ich weiß nicht.
Also das was ich gelesen hab ist, was die NPCs sagen ist, wenn du stirbst, verlierst du die...
Also du hast in der Stadt so einen Pot, den kannst du auslösen.
In den Pot kommen Levelpunkte rein, kommen gefundene Schätze rein und diesen Pot kannst du quasi mit Gold auslösen und kriegst dann quasi...
Umso mehr in dem Pot drinne ist, umso besseres Loot kriegst du.
Und der Pot verschwindet, wenn du stirbst. Dann musst du ihn neu füllen.
Und dann noch ne Sache, die mir aber ziemlich egal ist, wenn du stirbst, zählt also dein Progress für das Leaderboard zählt bloß bis zum ersten Death.
Was aber für's Meer, vollkommen egal ist.
Also verlierst hauptsächlich quasi deine aufgelevelte Loot-Kiste.
In der Stadt ist es aber nicht schlimm, das hast du in der Stunde wieder gleichgefüllt, wenn sie voll ist.
Was hab ich, wo muss ich denn hin?
Ah, ich bin falsch.
Nee.
Schon hin?
Ich glaub da war ne Tür, kann es sein, dass da rechts ne Tür war?
Wo ist die Facecam, LOL.
Ja, heute nicht.
Ich weiß, ich bin ja bekannt für meine Facecam Streams.
Sag mal ernsthaft Leute, wo geht's denn lang?
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Hier waren wir schon.
Hier geht's hoch, ah hier.
Goat-Splashen.
Ohne China-Cam, ja die China-Cam kommt ja in die Klingel unten.
Ich hab noch ein bisschen weiter programmiert an der China-Cam Gegensprechanlage.
Also ich hab das jetzt auf die Linux-Kiste gepackt, die wir letztens installiert haben zusammen und streben.
Mittlerweile funktioniert's ganz gut.
Ich hab noch eingebaut, dass die Gegensprechfunktion jetzt in beide Richtungen halt funktioniert.
Also sprich, dass man hört und, also dass man den Typ vor der Cam sieht, hört und er einen selbst hört.
Sogar von iOS-Geräten.
Was wieder komplizierter war.
Also wirklich, das ist jetzt das erste Mal, dass ich mich mit ein bisschen Entwicklung für iOS beschäftigt hab.
Im Rahmen von dieser China-Cam.
Und ich hab jetzt schon keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Vor allem, ich hab mal geguckt, was man machen muss.
Android geht ja.
Das Problem auf Android war, dass das ein H.264-Stream war.
Und Chrome quasi H.264-Web-RTC-Streams nur auf auserwählte Hardware unterstützt.
Hab ich Firefox genommen gegen Sofort.
Eigentlich auch affisch, oder?
Eigentlich auch richtig affisch.
Sag mal, knackst mein Audio heute irgendwie oder so?
Weil ich hab das Noise-Gate eingeschaltet.
Vorm OBS, aber es sollte nichts knacksen, ne?
Alles gut, okay.
Ja, iOS hat theoretisch auch das Potenzial, dass man dafür angenehm entwickeln könnte.
Ich mein, die Geräte sind relativ übersichtlich, wie viel es da gibt.
Das könnte alles relativ klar sein.
Aber ich mein, es fängt ja schon mal damit an.
Warte, mach ich jetzt auf.
Was denn hier?
Gebashed gerade.
Ich hab mich nämlich mal schlau gemacht, was man alles braucht, um zum Beispiel so eine
richtige iOS-App zu entwickeln.
Du brauchst meistens einen Mac dafür, weil du brauchst am Ende, egal mit was du es entwickelst,
brauchst du zum Abschließenden kompilieren und zum Abschließenden App-Dings erzeugen,
brauchst du Xcode und das läuft halt nur unter Mac.
Und dann gibt es noch eine andere Variante, dass man das Erzeugen der App quasi über
eine Online-Service macht, die dann wohl wiederum einen Mac haben und dann selbst einen
Mac nicht braucht.
Aber das ist dann halt auch nicht unbedingt die Technologie, die man verwenden will, sondern
die, die das halt unterstützen.
Also es ist wirklich, es ist grausig und dazu kommt, also Android ist viel, viel einfacher,
aber dazu kommt noch die Gangelung von Apple.
Also selbst wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ich würde gerne was für mich entwickeln.
Ich will es gar nicht in den App Store machen.
Du kannst, wenn du deine App, wenn du die signest und quasi auf dein, auf dein eigenes
iOS-Gerät kopierst, dann darfst du sie bloß sieben Tage benutzen.
Deine eigene App, auf deinem eigenen iOS-Gerät darfst du nur sieben Tage verwenden, weil
Apple dich sonst löscht.
Es sei denn, du holst dir für 100 Euro im Jahr den Apple, so einen Apple Def-Account.
Dann geht das wieder.
Also sprich, Apple erlaubt dir deine eigene App auf deinem eigenen iOS-Gerät nur sieben
Tage zu verwenden.
Das ist schon geil, oder?
Ja, da dachte ich, genau das habe ich mir auch gedacht, als ich das gelesen habe.
Genau so habe ich davor gesagt, wenn das ist mein iOS-Gerät und meine App, warum darf
ich die bloß sieben Tage verwenden?
Es gibt wohl irgendwelche Tricks, die man machen kann.
Man kann wohl irgendwie mit dem Studio-Impactor irgendwie Zeit lauten, aber dann weiß ich
auch nicht, ob das sieben-Tage-Limit wirklich zuverlässig aufgehoben wird.
Also es ist nicht schön.
Nee, wirklich nicht.
Zumal man immer noch einen Mac braucht, um die App zu erzeugen.
Es sei denn, man benutzt so einen Service wie Expo für React Native, die das dann für
dich kompilieren.
Das würde funktionieren.
Ja, das hat beides seine Daseinsberechtigung, sehe ich auch so.
Allerdings, so wie ich es aktuell sehe, macht Apple den Entwicklern unnötig das Leben schwer.
Und seinen Benutzern auch unnötig das Leben schwer, weil sie vor allem, wenn man sich
mal anguckt, was Safari an neuen Technologien unterstützt, ziemlich rückständig sind.
So, haben wir alles jetzt?
Nee, eins fehlt noch.
Ah, da oben.
Ja, da waren wir noch nicht.
Also iOS Safari unterstützt saumäßig vieles Zeug nicht.
Fullscreen, kannste nicht.
Vor allem, na gut, Fullscreen kann ich noch verstehen, dass Apple sagt, ah, dazu entspricht
nicht unsere Philosophie.
Aber zum Beispiel ihre Progressive Web App Unterstützung ist halt auch der Witz.
Du kannst dir, die App kannst du dir auch ins Home, ins Startmenü, nee, wie heißt
das, Fullscreen, kannst du dir machen.
Wenn du sie startest, wirst du aber feststellen, dass, äh, wenn du sie startest, nicht die
normale Safari-Version gestartet wird, sondern so eine super abgespeckte Safari-Version,
die quasi weder zum Beispiel Mikrofon und Kamera, noch nicht mal mit Dialog, sondern
gar nicht unterstützt, richtig.
Ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz komisch.
Was hab ich vergessen?
Spinne, wo ist die denn?
Glaub ich jetzt nicht, ich hab vergessen, hier eine Spinne zu bashen.
Soll ich jetzt noch mal das ganze, ah, da unten muss ich hin.
Soll ich noch mal das ganze Level ablaufen, dass ich jetzt die, die, die Spinne gebashed
kriege.
Ah, da unten ist die Spinne.
Unten ist die Spinne eingegeben.
Wo ist die Spinne?
Äh, nein, nein, hier ist nicht die, ah, null, Stellspinne.
So, wenn wir jetzt den Dungeon durch haben, wie viel brauchen wir noch, dann holen wir
ab.
Ah, letztes, letztes, äh, letzte Abschnitt.
Dann holen wir, und ich sag dir, Leute, in der Stadt, wir haben mittlerweile unsere Loot-Kiste
so voll, wenn wir, wenn wir die jetzt abholen, dann kriegen wir bestimmt richtig geiles
Zeug.
Oh, was denn das?
Irgendwas, wo ich den Spell cancelen muss auf jeden Fall.
Schau mal gut.
Wach ist tot.
Wach ist platt.
Gut.
Nein.
Wach ist tot.
Einfach Auto-Attacken, diese Enrage-Dinger kann man nicht angreifen, sonst kriegt man
einfach das Enrage und so halt.
Also das hat schon vom Gameplay her, finde ich, haben sie es echt cool gemacht.
Okay, Auto-Attack, das Ding mal kaputt jetzt, geiler Warrior.
Ja, so ist es, Hopfwiesel.
Kamarast.
Ja, also.
Was noch cool wäre, wenn man sich ins Feuer stellt, dass da Ver-Eisungseffekt weggeht.
Wäre ja irgendwie auch logisch, ne?
Weil man kann ja schlecht Feuer-Damage kriegen und Eis-Damage gleichzeitig.
Dis-Abo macht man ja.
Ja, mein D ist richtig, Hopfwiesel hat es ankannt.
Man deabonniert heute nicht, weil man disabot.
Soll man ein brauchbares Linux für Smartphones, das haben sie ja probiert.
Es gab ja die Firefox-Variante und die Ubuntu-Variante, das hat sie jetzt.
Ich glaube, für ein weiteres OS auf dem Smartphone-Markt wird es halt schwierig.
Dafür gibt es einfach schon zu viel für Android und für iOS.
Ich meine, Android ist ja unangefochten vorne.
Muss man nicht diskutieren, das ist so, was die Verbreitung angeht.
Kann man sich jede Statistik angucken.
Und ich finde, es gibt zwar unter Android auch ein paar Dinge, die sehr nervig sind.
Aber entwicklertechnisch muss ich sagen, umsterben.
Alterfuck.
Es regt sich immer wieder das Viech.
Es wird so nice werden, wenn wir in die Stadt kommen.
Also wenn ich als Entwickler die Auswahl hätte, ob Android oder iOS,
dann würde ich auf jeden Fall Android nehmen.
Und mittlerweile, ich meine, iOS hat irgendwie so 18, 19, 20% Anteil.
Und der Rest ist fast alles Android.
Wobei man halt wahrscheinlich auf iOS auch gut Kohle verdienen kann.
Android hat auch viele Sachen, die mir auf den Keks gehen.
Das Problem ist, das sind immer so Kleinkrams, wo mir dann immer so Spontanikseinfälle,
zum Beispiel, wie manche Apps aufgebaut sind.
Ich meine, vor allem die offiziellen Apps.
Das Interface von der, weißt du, da haben sie ihr Materialdesign,
ihre Guidelines, wie Apps aussehen sollen.
Und da guckt euch die YouTube-App an, die sich nicht mal an die eigenen Google-Zeug hält.
Das ist halt lächerlich irgendwo, ne?
Das ist, ja, Desmond, das ist auch eine Sache,
dass es so viele unterschiedliche Android-Versionen gibt.
Das ist halt alles Probleme.
So, mal aus Anwender-Sicht denke ich halt, iOS ist eine super Geschichte für,
was man einfach nur benutzen will, ja?
Also als reine Anwendungsgeschichte, wenn man, keine Ahnung,
die Oma auf dem Sofa, wenn die PDFs lesen will oder E-Books oder sowas,
ein bisschen im Internet gucken und so, ist das geil.
Sobald du ein bisschen damit was machen willst,
auch automatisierungstechnisch, hast du halt mit iOS gar keine Chancen.
Mit Android kannst du alles machen.
Sogar ungeroutet fast alles.
Das ist aber halt so eine Designfrage,
weil Apple erlaubt halt selbst mit Zustimmung nicht,
dass Programme automatisch was machen.
Du brauchst immer User-Interaktion.
Das ist so eine Designgeschichte von Apple.
Das wollen die so.
Also sprich, sowas wie Tasker unter Android wird das unter iOS halt nie geben,
weil Apple sagt, das will man nicht.
Was ja auch wiederum Vorteile hat, so ist es nicht.
Du kannst dich zumindest als Anwender darauf entlassen,
dass manche Sachen halt eben nicht passieren.
Aber mir ist das ein bisschen zu restriktiv.
Vor allem im Hinblick, dass man ja auch gar nicht sagen kann,
ja, wir fragen, wir holen uns die Erlaubnis vom Anwender.
Geht ja auch nicht.
Was halt nicht funktioniert, also so ein Beispiel zum Beispiel, ja.
Weil angenommen man hat,
weil wie gesagt dafür habe ich ja letztens ein bisschen was gebastelt hier auch on stream.
Angenommen man hat eine Kamera am Eingang.
Und man möchte jetzt, wenn man klingelt,
möchte man auf dem Tablet automatisch die App öffnen mit,
wo man seine Kameras alle drin hat.
Und die Kamera halt eben öffnen, die am Tor ist.
Unter Android ist das kein Problem.
Unter Android nimmst du dir irgendwie eine x-beliebige App,
die deine Kamera feeds kann.
Tinycam oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Und dann installierst du dir entweder Tasker oder irgendein,
nennen wir mal Tasker, das ist so das verbreitetste.
Und dann schickst du einfach eine Nachricht an Tasker
oder Tasker polt irgendeine Uhr oder sonst was.
Quasi wenn es geklingelt hat, dann öffne diese App.
Easy, das ist wirklich mega easy unter Android.
Und unter iOS ist das designtechnisch nicht vorgesehen.
Das geht nicht.
Wir haben vorhin noch ein paar Sachen vergessen.
Das funktioniert unter iOS.
Jaja klar, du kannst vieles unter iOS machen.
Du brauchst dann aber halt eine App, die exakt das macht,
was du möchtest, was es halt nicht gibt oder selten gibt.
Dadurch, dass du halt bei Android so viel automatisch machen kannst,
kannst du halt auch die Sachen miteinander kombinieren.
Was halt cool ist, du nimmst deine App, wo du deine Kameras drin hast
und du bekommst irgendwo über irgendwie einen anderen Weg mitgeteilt,
wenn es klingelt und darauf kannst du halt reagieren.
Das geht halt so unter iOS nicht.
Unter iOS bräuchtest du eine App, die halt genau das implementiert hat,
so wie du das brauchst.
Was es halt so meistens nicht...
Da bräuchtest du so eine Kombination aus SIP, App für Call Kit.
Du bräuchtest da Unterstützung für die Kameras, Teams.
Machbar ist es, aber gibt es nicht.
Und die Sache ist halt unter Android.
Muss es das nicht geben?
Also unter Android kannst du dir sowas halt total simpel selbst machen.
Du nimmst eine App, die Kameras anzeigen lassen kannst,
machst zum Beispiel Tasker drauf und öffnest die App automatisch, wenn es klingelt.
Für so Sachen ist Android ganz toll.
Meilenwald voraus, auch was viele Sachen angeht,
was der Browser standardmäßig kann.
Vergleiche ich zu Safari.
Dafür hat halt iOS andere Designansätze.
Es ist ja so, dass wenn man es eben...
Fuck, ich muss mal kurz hier raus.
Wenn man es eben gar nicht erlaubt,
dann kann es auch gar keine Probleme geben.
Aber wenn man unter iOS sowas nicht erlaubt,
dann kann auch das kein Entwickler missbrauchen irgendwie.
Wenn iOS Policy ist, es muss eine User-Aktion die Sache triggern,
dann ist das halt so.
Da kann ich aber auch als jemand,
der das kann ich auch nicht missbrauchen.
Und der User weiß genau, was passiert.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber schreiten, was besser ist.
Wenn man es allerdings haben will,
und ich will es ja bei mir haben,
weil ich ja z.B. die Frontkamera integrieren will,
dann geht es mir auf den Keks,
dass ich es nicht machen kann unter iOS,
aber unter Android-Easy-Game.
Was ist hier?
Oh, fuck, fuck, ich bin mit reingerannt.
Ich kack nur.
Nein, Alter, warum rennst du in die falsche Richtung?
Aha.
Wieder zurückgerannt.
Also ich denke, es hat beides eine Daseinsberechtigung.
Obwohl ich eigentlich so viel mehr Android-Geräte habe als iOS-Geräte,
war ich ja in der Vergangenheit relativ pro iOS,
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen,
es schwankt bei mir,
und vor allem jetzt auch wegen dieser App-Bastel-Geschichte,
schwankt bei mir immer mehr in Richtung
nächste Geräte werden nur noch Android.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
das Interface und die Konsistenz der ganzen Geschichte,
da finde ich wiederum iOS-Meilen weit vorne.
Bei Android kannst du im Endeffekt alles machen,
aber du kannst doch jeden Scheiß machen.
Wie was, wie, ey, wie soll ich denn jetzt bashen da drinnen?
Egal, YOLO.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Einfach hack'n'slayen easy.
Eats as fuck.
Ich kann hier gar nichts.
Das hoffe ich auch.
Was ich sogar schön gefunden hätte,
wenn sich eines der anderen Dinger durchgesetzt hätte,
wenn das Microsoft nicht so verkackt hätte,
mit Windows-Dings, Mobile,
wenn sich vielleicht Ubuntu oder Firefox durchgesetzt hätte,
weil ich finde, man sieht's bei Konsolen ganz gut,
dass drei Anbieter eigentlich ganz gut sind.
Drei Anbieter fände ich eigentlich am besten.
Apple ist so ein bisschen das neue Microsoft,
was Standards unterstützen und extra Würste angeht.
Ich mein, in der Speck von WebRTC steht drinnen
die
Speck von WebRTC steht drinnen,
unser Codec ist VP8 und top mit VP9 als Extension.
Ich find's fragwürdig, ehrlich gesagt,
weil H264 das verbreitetste ist eigentlich,
aber es steht ein Speck drinnen.
Was macht Apple?
Sie implementieren H264 für WebRTC.
Und den offiziell geforderten Codec nicht,
wo man sich auch denkt,
komm an Brach, warum?
Wenn sie zusätzlich H264 gemacht hätte,
hätte er keine Probleme gehabt.
So, ich glaube, wir sind durch.
Wir können unser Loot abholen.
Ein sehr, sehr nicees Loot wird das jetzt.
Ich hoffe auf AC1, sagt Europat.
AC1, ist das das neue WLAN?
Ist das das 3 Gigabit oder sowas WLAN?
Nee, das sieht doch anders, oder?
Was ist AC1?
Ach, AV1!
AV1 ist doch alt, oder?
Ist AV1 nicht die Konkurrenz gewesen zu H264?
Ach nee, V1 ist H265, oder?
Dass sie das Zeug nicht immer griffig nennen können.
Das muss man sagen, das kann Apple.
Sollen das Zeug griffig nennen?
Die sollen das Next-Gen-Hypercodec nennen oder so.
Dann weißt du wenigstens, was Sache ist.
Wir haben doch alles, oder?
Wir gehen erstmal back to town und holen unser Loot.
Oh, das wird richtig nice, das Loot gibt es jetzt.
Jetzt holen wir unser Loot ab.
Haben wir da drin Golden Prize?
Gut, Gold braucht kein Mensch, Gold haben wir schon genug.
Haben wir eine Rune?
Auch gut.
Dass das Game hat, findet ihr nicht auch?
Das Game hat irgendwie so satisfying Sounds, oder?
Das fühlt sich an, als hat man in irgendeinem Ingame-Shop was gekauft,
aber es ist nicht Ingame-Shop.
Was gibt es hier?
Sounds of Essen.
Chances?
Das ist ganz gut eigentlich.
Amulet auf Mana, das brauchen wir nicht.
Better chance to hit Goats.
Das könnten wir echt neben so viele Goats wie in letzter Zeit bashen.
Nicht das Overwatch Goats.
Healers Charge of Time.
Oh, das ist doch ganz nice, das nennen wir.
Select.
Town Portal?
Nein, den Spell verwenden wir auch schon nicht.
Die Level sind so klein, man kann einfach zur Treppe laufen.
Echt kein Ding.
Hast du schon mal die Souls-Reihe gespielt?
Also Onstream nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht, ob ich mir das Onstream gebe.
Rage Mode ist real.
Was gab es als letztes?
War noch irgendwas geiles, weil wir können uns einen neuen Slot holen.
Neue Slots sind nie verkehrt.
Wir upgraden jetzt erstmal unser Schild.
Wir müssen erstmal unser Schild upgraden.
Nicht viel zu oft.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Der Skeleton Build, was bringt der?
Cooldowns Reduced brauchen wir nicht.
Wir upgraden auf jeden Fall mal das Schild.
50% Missile ist sehr nice.
Da kann ich random irgendwas rein machen.
Das Schild muss 50% sein, das ist schon mal gut.
Das können wir noch upgraden von uns.
Die Rüstung, wie sieht es mit der Rüstung aus?
Können wir die Rüstung upgraden?
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so übel.
Amulett?
Das Amulett bringt das?
Achso, alle 2 Sekunden.
Das könnte man upgraden.
Live-Rune brauchen wir dafür.
Machen wir.
Wir upgraden das Amulett.
Oh, eine Live-Rune.
Eine Live-Rune kriegt man damit.
Eine Live-Rune.
Wo ist das Amulett?
Es braucht 2 Live-Runen.
2 Live-Runen.
Was?
Moment.
Füß-Runes.
Das?
Ich muss ja auf Füß drücken.
Alles klar.
Jetzt haben wir das Amulett am Start.
Upgrade Level 2.
Sehr schön.
So, und jetzt kann man das noch upgraden.
Oh, das ist cool.
Das upgraden wir noch.
Nein, das brauchen wir wieder 2 Live-Rune.
2 Live-Rune haben wir nicht.
Ich würde sagen, wir anlocken noch einen Slot.
Wir holen uns noch einen Slot.
Ach, das müsste anlocken.
Ja, Bad Company 2.
Immer noch übelst nicees Game.
So, und jetzt machen wir das so.
Zack.
Und packen da das mit rein.
Das ist doch nice.
Jetzt haben wir was, was uns Gift und Gedöns heilen kann.
Gut, weiter geht's.
Also ich muss sagen, mit diesem Amazon Fire HD 10 Android Ding,
ich habe ja 2 Stück bestellt, als die im Angebot waren, bin ich echt zufrieden.
Wie gesagt, ich habe die auch komplett Custom Launcher Amazon runtergerootet.
Also quasi komplett.
Quasi komplett Amazon entfernt mehr oder weniger.
Aber an sich für den Preis wirklich ein Top Tablet.
Very big, 75 Minuten.
Gibt es aber viele Rewards.
Ja, komm Leute.
Bam.
Very big.
Massive.
70 Minuten, easy, start.
Hohoho.
Das Spiel war übelst bock.
Das ist auch sowieso so ein Geheimtipp Ding gewesen.
Hätte ich das nicht im Stream gesehen?
Very big.
Ich habe das Spiel euch bei Dan's Game gesehen im Stream.
Und er hatte einen Spinnenboss, der hat sich,
der hat sich genannt einen Spinnenboss, Harry Willi.
Spinnenboss.
Vielleicht ein bisschen unglücklich, die Kombination.
Erinnert sich noch einer an die Diablo 2 Gegner, die waren ja auch ganz, ganz hart.
Warum hat jedes Action RPG eigentlich so komische Goatman oder so komische Ziegen Gegner?
Was ist mit den Ziegen los?
Warum, warum?
Aber nur, aber nur ins Action RPGs, ansonsten gibt es nie Ziegen als Gegner.
Oh, was sind das für fette Typen?
X, X, L, Calzone.
Oh, jetzt wo du das so schreibst, ich habe Hunger.
Ja, Calzone und Pizza könnte ich jetzt auch drücken.
Was ich nicht mag ist, da wird wahrscheinlich der Italiener ins Übel schreiben.
Was ich bei Calzone und Pizza nicht mag ist, wenn da Pilze drin sind.
Weil, die machen das immer so matschig.
Ich weiß, irgendwie scheinen Pilze da dazu zu gehören, aber die Pilze machen das immer so matschig.
Wenn das einfach nur Salami, Schinken, Käse, äh, was, was, keine Ahnung.
Was könnte man da machen anstatt Pilze?
Salami, Schinken, Käse, Sardellen oder so.
Wäre mir viel lieber.
Weil Pilze machen das so matschig.
Was isst ihr eigentlich zu Silvester?
Nimmt ihr irgendwie die Special oder geht ihr euch besaufen oder was ist das?
Also ich war nicht mal besoffen, seit ich beim Zivildienst war oder schon ewig her.
Das war das letzte Mal, wo ich mich richtig besoffen habe und es war so ätzend,
dass ich mir danach gesagt habe, das muss nicht sein.
Ich weiß, viele erreichen diesen Punkt wahrscheinlich nie.
Richtig übertreiben, das war ich nimmer.
Das war so schlimm, dass ich mir gedacht habe, nein.
Beim Zivildienst, da musst du zweimal während du Zivildienst machst,
muss man zu irgendeinem komischen Kurs gehen und der eine ist zwei Tage.
Könnt ihr euch ja mal überlegen.
War sie gefühlt 100 Typen oder so auf einem Haufen über Nacht.
Es ist klar, dass die sich irgendwie besaufen in dem Alter.
Also irgendwie 20, 21, 22.
Und das war so schlimm, aber irgendwie ging es so scheiße.
Und am anderen Tag war ja der eigentliche Kurs, weshalb ich da hingehen sollte.
Ich musste dann auch während dem Kurs quasi laufen mit raus und kotzen.
Ich habe es ja auch taktisch sehr ungeschickt gemacht.
Ich bin dann morgens aufgewacht und habe gedacht, mir ging es zwar schade,
aber jetzt ist es eigentlich wieder gut.
Und bin dann runtergegangen in die Kantine und habe erst einmal
eine komplette eiskalte Fanta aus dem Automat getrunken.
Das war echt der Fehler.
Danach ging es mir für die nächsten zwei Tage scheiße.
Inklusive dem Tag, wo dieser komische Kurs war.
Und seitdem, es hat mich aber echt so bekehrt, seitdem saube ich mich nicht mehr.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich komplett absent bin und gar nichts trinke.
Klar, aber ich saube mich nicht mehr.
Und das habe ich jetzt seit über zehn Jahren schon durchgehalten.
Mein Zivilismus ist auch schon ein bisschen her.
Kommen wir hier neben? Ach, hier neben müssen wir auch noch hin.
Auto-Attack, please.
Wo warst du beim Zivilismus? Ich war in einer behinderten Werkstatt.
Das war eigentlich nice.
Ich wusste am Anfang gar nicht, wie ich genau mit den Leuten umgehen soll.
Ich meine, klar, man hat da schon ein bisschen Berührungsängste.
Weil, weil, ich hatte mit so Leuten auch nichts zu tun gehabt vorher.
Null.
Aber nach einer Zeit ging das dann und das war eigentlich echt cool.
Ich fand das ganz sinnvoll.
Und das ist eine Sache, die würde ich auch jemandem empfehlen, wenn er mich fragt, so, wo er hingehen soll.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Besser, als die den ganzen Tag auf dem Hochstand im Ball sitzen oder so.
Und außerdem haben wir da viel zu wenig Leute.
Zumal, die Sache hat sich jetzt eh erledigt, gibt es hier alles gar nicht mehr.
Gibt es hier gar nicht mehr.
Ist hier erledigt.
Ah, SilentPan, du kommst aus der Schweiz oder Österreich?
Österreicher.
Ja, mein Bundesheer klingt sehr nach Österreich.
Jetzt kann man aufgefallen, wie unrealistisch auch, also ich habe mich ja schon heute oft über die Sounds in Games,
und so Damage Sounds in Games ausgelassen, aber auch mal, wie mir gerade eingefallen ist, wie unrealistisch das ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr lauft durchs Feuer, ne, und das einzige, was ihr dann beim machen würdet, ist...
Hallo?
Wenn ich durch so Flammen laufen würde, würde ich bestimmt nicht machen.
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich ganz anderes Zeug machen.
Spinnengegner sind nervig.
Oder was?
Ich muss sagen, der Stream ist heute richtig nice und entspannt.
XX Calzone.
Ja, mit was war es denn?
So, der Klassiker, Salami, Schinken, Pilze?
Oder hast du Special Mischung?
Was? Die Spinne kann stannen?
Ich glaube, ich bestelle mir jetzt auch eine Pizza.
Weil ich die letzten Tage eigentlich wirklich genug gefressen habe.
Aber so eine Person, so eine Person, dass sie irgendwie so Pizza wird, hätte ich jetzt auch schon Bock auf.
Eine sehr, sehr nice Pizza.
Jetzt keiner gecheckt.
Muss den Kabub unbedingt mal wieder anrufen.
Wir haben vor einer Weile mal wieder, also irgendwie vor einem Monat oder so, mal wieder ein paar Messages geschrieben.
Und mit Essen gehen.
Vielleicht mal machen.
Ja, das muss ja mit dem Channel irgendwie anfangen.
Das heißt, das müsste...
Keine Ahnung.
Wupplos ist ein Scheiß-Channel-Name für Emotes. Wupp, Wupp, Wupp-Henne oder so, könnte man da höchstens machen.
Ja, Eiskäuter, das stimmt schon.
Was ist denn jetzt für ein...
Spider Kangaroos.
Guck!
Jetzt ging gerade, ich war nicht auf Tap.
Ich war nicht auf Tap.
Ich ging einfach so auf Tap.
Andersherz, genau.
Spider Kangaroos.
Die Gegner können nix, da muss ich einfach nur stehen bleiben und Knopf drücken.
Dann heilen, drücken und Herzchen ansammeln.
Perfekt.
Wupp, ich würde sagen, ein B machen wir, wenn das Twitch zulässt.
Wupp-Keks, Wupp-Monka, Wupp-Lull, Wupp-Grill.
Wupp-Rockers muss er auf jeden Fall...
Ich muss erstmal jemand finden, der gut Emotes macht.
Wupp-Naisu, ja, unbedingt.
Der gut Emotes macht und...
Ja, warte, von dem auch gar nichts, dass er das umsonst macht oder so.
Aber man muss erstmal jemand finden.
Und das muss einem dann auch gefallen.
Man kann dafür sogar ein bisschen Kohle ausgeben.
Ich muss erstmal Partner werden, das ist richtig.
Das ist erstmal die Voraussetzung dafür.
Ich glaube, es gibt keinen, der so lange gebraucht hat, bis er das endlich macht, oder?
Die meisten machen das instant, sobald sie können.
Weißt du, der Emote-Style passt?
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie die aussehen bei denen.
Ich weiß nämlich auch gar nicht, wie ich das haben will, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich bin mal sowas echt sehr unkreativ.
Ja, und selbst Zombie.
Die Spider kann echt nichts.
Ich werde jetzt als nächstes versuchen, noch die letzten zwei Slots freizuschalten.
Weil dann kann ich vier Abilities nehmen und Rest Passive.
Das ist gut, weil auf fünf komme ich eh schon immer so richtig mit dem Finger.
Metal Spoder, ja.
Solche Emotes kann ich ja schlecht machen, weil da ist ja ein Face drauf.
Was bei mir schwierig wird.
Bleibt nur Webcam-Stream.
Die L.
Das ist gut zu wissen.
Aha.
Hast du den Hino Kuni 2 gespielt? Nein.
Ich habe den ersten gespielt, den fand ich gut.
Bis zur Hälfte ungefähr.
Nach was irgendwie ein bisschen, was weiß ich so, uninspiriert.
Aber ich habe gehört, dass der zweite nicht so geil ist.
Also nicht so gut wie der erste.
Eigentlich gehört, kann man kein viel hören, wenn er total lang ist.
Level Up haben wir.
Zwei Level Ups.
Ich finde übrigens, die haben das ganz nice hier gemacht, dass man die Bonuspunkte,
man bekommt quasi, egal wie man seine Skillpunkte setzt, bekommt man immer auch den anderen
Skillpunkt, wenn man diesen Topf aus dem Dorf holt.
Irgendwie sind die Level einfacher geworden, das zwischenseitig war mal echt schwierig.
Jetzt eigentlich.
Pass auf, sagt er und verreckt.
Noch nie von Bock auf Demos gehört, ja ich bis gestern auch nicht.
Ist aber sehr nice an Diablo eins angelegt, halt so ein bisschen auf Schienen, wie man
hier sieht.
Aber auch saumig viel Diablo eins Referenzen.
Und spielt sich eigentlich echt nice, macht Bock.
Hätte ich nicht erwartet, ja.
Ist ganz schön lang hier der Dungeon.
Das Spiel ist super entspannend.
Seit ich hab hier nur noch die Woche Urlaub, das heißt ich muss mich jetzt, kann ich die
ganze Zeit irgendwas machen?
Ich muss mich jetzt mal ein bisschen ausrollen.
Hat sich das ja überhaupt nicht belohnt.
Und was gibt es besseres als ein bisschen Monsterschmerzlohn?
Oder komische Zombie-Kängurus oder was das sein soll.
Das ist der einzige Referenz auf Diablo, das stimmt.
Ich mein sagen sie ja indirekt auch schon mit ihren, was die NPCs im Dorf sagen.
Bis Februar, das ist natürlich sehr nice.
Oh, der will mich bashen glaube ich.
Aber keine Chance, den Basher basht keiner.
Jetzt bringt man meine Feuerachse wenigstens was.
Direkt.
Aber konstante 144 FPS.
Bestimmt ein Unity-Game, was mein ihr?
Irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, es ist ein Unity-Game.
Wo man wieder sieht, dass man auch mit Unity gute Sachen machen kann.
RPG Maker ist klar.
Der spreit da eigentlich den grünen Schleim hin.
Ach das fiel ich da.
Hast du eigentlich noch Kontakt mit anderen?
Ne, wir hatten ja auch nicht wirklich Kontakt, wir haben ein paar Videos geschickt.
Ich gucke ihn auch nicht mehr, das liegt nicht auf ihm, sondern weil mich Black Ops nicht großartig interessiert.
Schön großer Dungeon.
Ja über die halbe App ist klar.
Hier ist die Schicht drunter.
Moment, gehts wieder zurück? Was ist das?
Das Game könnte ein bisschen mehr Movement Abilities noch vertragen, finde ich.
Ah nice, jetzt bin ich immun gegen...
Das muss ich mal öfters verwenden.
Custom Engine, ok.
Jetzt ist es nice, jetzt bin ich immun gegen Poison, gegen alles, dann kann ich sie bashen.
Cancel, cancel.
Aber wenn man immun ist, ist es nice, dann fährt man ordentlich Damage.
Jetzt wird nicht eingefroren worden, kack.
Jetzt wird man eingefroren.
Mal kurz den anderen Duda unten bashen.
Hallo, sterben. Will er nicht.
Nur kann man ordentlich leben.
Wow, ist aber voll hier.
Sind das zwei Bosse irgendwie?
Gefühlt sind das zwei Bosse.
Abbrechen, abbrechen, abbrechen, jetzt Damage machen.
Da schon immer die Handwerfer, ganz gut, lecke.
Anstrengend.
Damage, recken.
Das kann man nicht mehr abbrechen.
Sie werden im Prinzip gefühlt einfach, das ist ja nicht so was, das schwer wäre.
Eat, das alles, du Eats.
Also auf gleich, gleich sterbe ich.
So einen komischen Bogi stellt er weg.
So mag ich das.
Muss ich nicht zu sehr konzentrieren, aber man hat trotzdem das Gefühl, man macht irgendwas Sinnvolles.
Miss, miss, miss, miss, miss.
Hier erst macht es. Erst mal looten, erst mal looten.
Wo ist er hin?
So eine Phase noch, da muss da Down sein.
Jetzt noch eine Phase.
Hoffentlich gibt es dafür ordentlich Loot.
Wäre nice, wenn man irgendwie neue Waffe kriegen würde oder so.
Was, gab es jetzt aber nicht für.
Ok, wo haben wir was übersehen, da müssen wir noch hin.
Aber wir hätten uns zwischendrin ohne Probleme heilen können.
5 was, 5 Gold, Bookcase.
Wo habe ich was übersehen, Gold, ok, gut.
Unten ist noch Gold, ja das holen wir dann. Wir gehen jetzt erst mal zum Bookcase.
Wo das?
Was brauchen wir jetzt noch?
Ich finde es aber gut, dass die haben das Anzeigen, wo der Rest ist.
Warte, ich hole mal kurz was zu essen, ich habe Hunger.
Oder mal gucken, wie viel haben wir da noch vom Dungeon.
Wir haben noch 2 Abschnitte.
Hauen wir die Golds noch um.
Na, heute haben wir uns so viel über MMOs und Gehirns ausgelassen.
Dass ich jetzt echt wieder Bock habe, ich Spock drauf habe ein gutes MMO zu spielen.
Irgendetwas in der Richtung, wie ich es erzählt habe.
Das ist einfach nicht meins, ich weiß auch gar nicht, was der Fabian da so geil dran findet.
Stimmt den Cash Shop.
Legendary.
Am liebsten sind wir Monster, die man einfach umhauen kann.
Ohne irgendwie war es einfach, Tasten gedrückt halten, bashen.
MMOs streamen, gibt ja keins.
Außerdem, ich glaube eine Sache, die nicht MMOs sind, sind gut zu spielen, aber ich glaube MMOs sind nicht gut zu spielen.
Dann überlegt euch mal, man würde jemanden zugucken, wie der in WoW levelt oder so, das gibt doch wahrscheinlich kaum was langweiliges.
Ja gut, dafür geht das, aber ich stelle mir das wahnsinnig langweilig vor.
Deswegen gibt es wahrscheinlich auch so wenig MMO-Streams auf Twitch.
Es gibt WoW, gab es je nachdem, was die Fahnen größere Streams, wobei das auch übelst eingebrochen ist in letzter Zeit.
Blizzard hatten wir auch schon öfters mal als Thema.
Und die haben wahrscheinlich dann auch nicht einfach nur gelevelt, sondern irgendwelche Rates gemacht, eine World First Try XY.
Wie soll das eigentlich darstellen?
Die Ammo ist richtig gut geworden, seitdem wir es abgecreated haben mit den Herztrops.
Der Max-Stream ist eher ein Podcast.
Ja, aber aktuell weiß ich gar nicht, was ich erzählen soll irgendwie.
Ich habe mir hier aber alles Mögliche heute schon ausgelassen.
Je nachdem, bin ich eigentlich online.
Ist schon ein bisschen.
3 oder 4 Stunden noch.
3 Stunden.
Ja, 4 Stunden 20, Leute.
Ja, die Zeit geht immer schnell rum.
Beim Stream so an.
Was ist das?
Besser Drop.
War das jetzt gerade sowas wie der Schatzgommel in Diablo 3?
Ausgewicht.
Wo ist er hin?
War da oben.
Teleport, Stellz, Gegner.
Der Boss kann nichts, das sagt, außer dass er zwischendurch immun wird.
Ich frage mich, warum Bosse einfach so immun werden dürfen und ich nicht.
Ruf dich.
Das war in Diablo 2 der schlimmste Kettenblitzgegner.
Da sind so viele Leute dran verreckt.
Oh.
Mal hier bleiben.
Jetzt wird er gebashed.
Er castet sich weg.
Jetzt müsste man aber gleich haben.
Nein, nicht casten.
Jawoll.
Gab es ein bisschen Zeug.
Wenn wir hier durch sind, muss ich was essen.
Ja, das war in Diablo 3.
Das war ganz merkwürdig am Anfang.
Das war nicht in Diablo 3.
In Diablo 3 war Inferno.
Aber das wurde nach guter alter Blizzard-Tradition kaputt genervt.
Haben wir jetzt alles?
Das haben wir doch schon.
Nee, waren wir nicht.
Sonst wäre da die komische Spinne nicht.
Ja, das haben sie irgendwie auch echt.
Aber gut, ich meine, wenn das Original-Team ja auch mittlerweile bei Path of Exile und bei Torchlight
und wo die überall gelandet sind.
Disarmor, das ist das Gegner von Disabo.
Oh, das ist cool.
Alle Schilder von Monstern kaputt machen auf dem Bildschirm.
Das wirkt übertrieben OP.
Ghost Rays Killer Crimson soll ganz gut sein, aber ich glaube, es kann aktuell nichts mit Path of Exile aufnehmen,
was so Hack and Slay Action-RPG-mäßig angeht.
Das ist einfach zu durchdacht, immer zu viel Content.
Das hat man von Anfang an schon gemerkt, weil es echt nice.
Eigentlich müsste ich wieder Path of Exile spielen, da hat man immer was zu tun.
Und sei es nur ein bisschen sinnlose Magic-Fine-Runs, weil es da sowas gibt.
Ich kann mich immer richtig dran erinnern, ich glaube, sowas gibt es da gar nicht.
Du machst die Maps Path of Exile.
Scrolls und Zeug.
Was ist da?
Poison Bomb.
Arnele-Style.
Wisst ihr, das Tolle ist, mittlerweile mit Twitch-Emails kann man alles darstellen.
Du könntest im Buch nur mit Twitch-Emails schreiben und eine sinnvolle Story erzählen.
Echt so mittlerweile.
So, was habe ich vergessen?
99 Gold, jetzt ernsthaft, wegen 99 Gold.
Wo habe ich das Gold vergessen?
Da, da ist es, ich sehe es.
Wegen einem Gold muss ich jetzt noch mal runter ran.
Jetzt zwei so Dinger noch.
Das ist der einzige Spruch, den der Typ wohl hat.
Aber die Dungeons werden auch größer.
Da ist noch eins drunter.
Aber was auch hier schon wieder schön ist, was in Diablo 3 auch nicht funktioniert am Anfang, ist random generated Maps.
Dann aber am Anfang in Diablo 3 nicht random.
Das ist aber super geil, in Diablo 3 haben sie einfach gesagt, die Maps sind random generiert.
Die Maps waren nie random generiert am Anfang.
Sie haben einfach gesagt, die Maps sind random generiert.
Wir wissen eigentlich, die Maps sind nicht random generiert, aber wir sagen, die Maps sind random generiert.
Werkt schon keiner.
Sonst debatet.
Ach guck mal, die Monster werden auch vergiftet, das fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Weiß, wenn ich den jetzt hier kille, dann wird der andere Dude auch vergiftet.
Nee, das ist der Boss.
Noch mehr und undifizierte Karten.
Das System gefällt mir schon mal ganz gut.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was sie aus dem Game machen noch. Ich sag's ja auch Early Access.
So sowas, was man ab und zu mal wieder spielen kann.
Und das ist doch nicht einmal gecrashed.
Was ja gefühlt auch bei den meisten Triple-A-Tier-Dolster ist.
So, jetzt machen wir erst mal die Kiste auf.
Auf, enteis dich mal.
Lauf los.
Warte mal, ganz gut, der Damage.
Freest.
Entfreest mich einfach mal.
Können sie mich noch mal freezen?
Keine Chance, schreckt.
Oh, ist ja unfair. Auto-Aim-Ice.
X-21.
Naja, besser im Sale als nicht im Sale.
Es ist ja gar nicht so beschissen.
Aber es fehlt ihm irgendwie so der Charme.
Auch irgendwie so die Liebe zum Detail.
Wieder so gewollt, aber nicht richtig gefunden.
Es ist aber ja nicht total kacke.
Genauso wie Black Ops 4, das ist auch nicht kacke.
Also wirklich begeistern tut es mich an.
Black Ops 4, hab ich irgendwo mal gehört, ist quasi eher ein Ingame-Shop als ein Spiel.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt.
Also da wo ich es gespielt habe, ging ja der Ingame-Shop noch nicht richtig.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es mittlerweile Echtgeld-Transaktionen gibt.
Ich bin gespannt, ob wirklich, also erstens ob wirklich Bad Company nächstes Jahr rauskommt.
Dieses Jahr, nächstes Jahr, wahrscheinlich nächstes.
Ob sie irgendwie das Serie treu bleiben.
Da bin ich ja fast noch gespannter drauf, als dass es überhaupt rauskommt.
Was wenn es rauskommen sollte, ob sie es verkacken werden oder nicht.
Da bin ich echt mega gespannt drauf.
Ob das, weil, ich mein, man kann nicht sagen, dass es Bad Company, da kann man kaum was verkacken.
Man kann verdammt viel verkacken bei.
Wenn man es nämlich von Leuten machen lässt, die eigentlich auch keine Ahnung haben, was das ausmacht.
Sie haben ja in dem Interview schon mal gesagt, so nach dem Motto, also Fans, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ihr mit Bad Company wollt.
Wir wissen überhaupt nicht, was das Game toll gemacht hat.
Hab ich auch gedacht, ja, ihr werdet vielleicht alle Leute rausschmeißen, schmeißen sollen.
Oder wer sagt, sie haben sich alle Leute gehen lassen sollen, die es wussten.
Oder vielleicht fragt mal eure Fans, sie sagen euch, was sie an Bad Company gut fanden.
Jetzt ist ja eine bescheuerte Ausrede, ne.
Dice Things hier, LA macht das ja, nicht die Schweden.
Da kommt der Medal of Honor Warfighter 2, oh mein, wann ist die überhaupt?
Ich blick da nicht mehr durch.
Das ist mir zu hoch alles, wer da wie, wo man was gemacht hat.
Ich glaub, das waren die Medal of Honor, die Warfailer-Tücken.
Ich fand das erste Medal of Honor Reboot gar nicht mal so beschissen.
Aber das zweite war mega scheiße.
Das war auch die schlechteste Singleplayer-Kampagne, die ich so in einem modernen-day-Military-Shooter je gesehen hab, Medal of Honor Warfighter.
Und der Warfighter war das zweite, ne, das zweite vom Reboot.
Das war so schlecht.
Das war so schlecht, das Singleplayer.
Die Multiplayer kann ich nicht allzu viel sagen, da hab ich nicht lange gespielt, hat mir ganz Spaß gemacht.
Aber das Singleplayer war so schlecht.
Es ist nicht so, dass, weißt du, die Call of Duty Singleplayer, die sind meistens nicht wirklich geil.
Aber die sind immer gut inszeniert und, aber das war gar nichts davon.
Das war also komplett gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Na mal, Gegner killen, please.
Man weiß ja, da gab's im Singleplayer so ne Mission und ich hab's noch nie offensichtlicher gesehen,
dass man auf Dächern rote, also es ist ja, es ist ja bei den meisten Singleplayer-Kampagnen immer so,
dass irgendwo rote Fässer rumstehen, die die Kill, die da anschließen kannst, dass sie explodieren.
Das ist ja normal.
Ja, Siebaro, schade, ist doch richtig.
Aha, neue Heel-Card.
Interessant. Wartet mal kurz.
Oh, wieder da.
Was war das denn?
Hä?
Warum sollte ich das denn nehmen im Vergleich zu meinem normalen Heel?
Warum, wozu, also was ist der Sinn von diesem Spell?
Achso, es ist ein Hott.
Also es ist ein Hott, der Mana kostet und keine Charges.
Ja, vielleicht mal wenn ich zu viel Mana übrig hab.
Ups, warum hat man Memetool ins Spiel minimiert, was soll das?
Ah, das ist praktisch gegen Feuer-Gegner.
Flüssel, sehr schön.
Oh, der frisst aber Damage der Gude.
Wie gefällt die Interaktion mit den Spells von den Gegnern?
Hier, der Boss kann nichts.
Es sackt.
Einfach linke Maus, dass sie gedrückt hat, ein Easy Kill.
One Hit.
Oh, und Feuer-Damage nehme ich auch kaum.
Easy Mode.
Memetool hätte mich fast gereckt, ja.
Das stimmt.
Hat mich irgendwie aus dem Game geworfen.
Müssen wir auch noch weitermachen.
Oh, sterben please.
Und danach können wir wieder fett Loot aus der Stadt holen.
Oh, XP Boost plus EXP.
Okay, was haben wir vergessen?
Zwei.
Wir haben vergessen zwei Sachen zu looten.
Irgendwo da rechts.
Da.
Wo ist das andere?
Unten.
Haben wir doch nicht so viel vergessen.
Ja, Pavillion.
War eine sehr nice Idee.
Ich war überrascht, dass überhaupt etwas eingefallen ist.
Weil es hat natürlich vorher erzählt so nach dem Motto, dass ich ihr natürlich nichts schenken muss.
Aber ihr wisst ja, wie das ist.
Umso mehr man darauf hingewiesen wird, dass man das nicht tun muss.
Umso mehr wird ja eigentlich erwartet, dass man das macht.
Die hat Schuhe bekommen. Slippy Schuhe.
Das sind so Schuhe, die kannst du in die Mikrowelle stecken.
Dann werden sie warm.
Weil Krills immer kalte Föße haben.
Genauso Haustuhe.
Für die Haustuhe auch.
Oh, die machen Damage.
Was nuket mich da eigentlich weg gerade von oben?
Irgendwelche komischen Bogenstälzer. Mal das Schild wieder upgraden.
Ich hab übrigens auch was gekriegt.
Zeig euch gleich.
Ich hab auch was gekriegt.
Gar nicht so blöd. Gar nicht so blöd.
Ich hab gekriegt.
Eigentlich gar nicht so blöd.
Ich hab hier auch ein bisschen Heimautomatisierungszeug gezeigt.
Dass sich das Krill überhaupt anhört.
Und das dann auch noch ganz cool findet.
Das hat mich schon mal schwer begeistert.
Und irgendwie hat man es da auch von dem Thema, dass es so bescheuert ist,
dass viele Hersteller mittlerweile Schrauben nehmen, die man nicht mal aufkriegt.
Und ich hatte mir allen Ernst ein Vera-Kraftform-Sechsteile-Torx-Schraubenset geschenkt.
Weil man da mit Torx-Schrauben aufkriegt.
Das ist doch echt nice, oder?
Da kann man doch wirklich nichts sagen.
Und vor allem ein Vera-Set. Das sind ja gute Dinger.
Das ist doch...
Das ist doch echt... Ich hab's noch nicht aufgemacht hier, aber...
Das ist doch echt nice.
Vera mit W, ja.
Nicht die andere Vera.
Take it easy, Toolfinder.
Ja, Torx-Schraubenzieher braucht man immer, das stimmt.
Das sind auch richtig gute. Also das ist wirklich nice.
So.
Wieder die Ecke gepfeffert. Aber das kann man echt gebrauchen.
Das ist auch schwierig, irgendwas zu finden.
Also mit Geschenken ist eh so eine Sache.
Das ist wirklich schwierig, was zu finden, was man...
Weil die Leute, die Geld verdienen, kaufen sich halt eh.
Man muss irgendwas finden, was der andere braucht.
Und ich richtig wusste, dass er es braucht.
Das ist wirklich schwierig.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah.
Wieder einfach mal den Boss spawnen.
Obwohl ich noch gar nicht so weit bin.
Ein hinterhältiger Boss.
Wir machen erst mal das andere kaputt.
Erst mal die Dinger verfolgen.
Oh.
Erst mal drumherum Kleinkram bashen.
So, und jetzt wird der Boss gebashed.
Heats AF.
Borders.
Ganz viel des Borders.
Das Game bräuchte mehr Movement Ability.
Hast du Torchlight gespielt? Das erste hab ich gespielt.
Ich hab auch Secret und so Zeug.
Ich hab relativ viele.
So, Hagen Sledinger gespielt.
Ich fand Secret, also das erste war mega geil.
Das zweite fand ich auch ganz gut.
Vor allem, weil es das damals auf der Xbox gegeben hat.
Leider überhaupt nicht...
Au.
Leider überhaupt nicht supportet wurde danach.
Release.
Jawoll, er ist down.
Jetzt muss er auch gleich durch sein.
Goats.
Das wird nächste Overwatch League Season lustig.
Wenn dann alle nur noch Goats und Tankgeschiss spielen.
Ist ja jetzt schon teilweise ätzend zu gucken.
Wieder ein Grund, warum sich Overwatch in die falsche Richtung entwickelt hat.
Von wegen Low-Skill-Tank-Basche.
Kein Overwatch gibt's. Nee, da gibt's keine Ziegen.
Aber eine sehr beliebte Team-Komponente.
Goats nach dem...
Ich glaube, nach dem Erfinder-Team.
Goats.
Okay, wo waren wir jetzt noch nicht?
Tja.
Nee, nee, Goats ist... Was ist ein Goats?
Goats ist...
Reinhardt, Zarya...
D.Va...
Ich krieg die auch...
Ach, ich krieg die aktuelle Goats-Kompo... Anna?
Ich spiel... Ich spiel kein Overwatch mehr.
Ist gar nicht mal was genau.
Goats... Goats-Komposition.
Genau geht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall Tank-Setup.
Auch genannt World of Tanks aktuell in Overwatch.
Wo geht's denn noch lang hier? Guck mal, wir haben noch...
Ah nee, hier.
Hier geht's lang, da geht's lang.
Da oben noch ein Barrel, dann haben wir's.
So, letztes Level.
Mal Level abholen.
Ich hab das Gefühl, mein Krieger hat größere Range gekriegt, irgendwie.
Was ist das denn?
Hat der Ghost. Hyper-Ghost.
Ich mach irgendwann auch mal so nen...
MMO, Hack'n'Slay...
Und ähm... äh, äh... äh, äh.
Oder, oder Attack Sound...
Und dann fragen alle Leute, wer hat an diesen geilen Character gevois acted?
noch nie so geile damage sounds gehört
in fabian lassen wir die monster sounds machen
falls ihr zufällig auch den stream vom friseur schaut fragt ihr das nächste mal ob er euch die
ob er euch die left 4 dead
witch sounds mal
zeigen kann wie die gehen die konter immer gut nachmachen
das hat er drauf gehabt dass das konter das konter richtig gut
Wo bleibt ein schleff von der drei von davon abgesehen dass welfs er irgendwie nicht hat mit teil drei
oh
was macht damage
Aber spart als boss wenn ich mit denen und ich mal fertig bin soll das
Ja ich habe ich habe gehört dass
Wie hieß architect
Ne
Das hat es das welf hat so dass das nicht so geil angekommen ist
Hat es jemand von euch gespielt und wie ist das so wenn man hört viel an der tachlange ist
Das taugt das das meint ihr das machen wird wird irgendwie hartstone konkurrenz machen ganz mir kaum vorstellen
Wie viel bosse kommen denn da bitteschön jetzt noch ein flammen
Einflammen die waren einfach die flame bosse einfach stehen bleiben und bashen
Wenn ich sterbe
Erst mal gift imun machen hier bei dem scheiß erst mal gift imun machen
Und die machen wir gerade ein bisschen viel damage die dinger
Schau mal kurz ab das der diablo nachfolger ja nicht ganz aber geht in die richtung macht auf jeden fall jetzt mal das gute spiel für zwischendurch
Jetzt geht er dauernd
Einflamme ist
Oh wie viel er kommt da jetzt warum wird der bildschirm so dunkel gleich haben wir dauernd gleich haben wir dauernd gleich geht er dauernd
Oh, oh, oh, oh fuck
Jetzt haben wir ihn gleich komm geh dauernd
Oh so viel zeug nice
Danach geht es in die city und geht loot abholen
Erstmal dass du auf twitch siehst ja da ist dass du auch am start bist
Ja meistens bin ich nur war ich in letzter zeit nur proga streams
Die aber wenn ich auf die zuschauerzahl gucke ich mein gut das game ist jetzt auch echt nicht was für jeden
Die proga streams interessieren relativ viele leute dass ich sehr nice finde letztens irgendwie mal die 300 zuschauer gehabt
Ohne große ankündigungen auf auf youtube oder bitte oder so
Ich dachte es geht vorbei
Moment nicht jetzt noch ein level runter nähe oder
Ja ich schätze noch eins runter das ist danach vorbei
Jetzt schon
Wer ist der entwickler in die return to games heißen die glaube ich
Ein kleines wahrscheinlich vermute mal irgendwie eins zwei mannen
So haben wir es jetzt wir haben es
Leveld not clear warum nicht warum ist es lewe not clear
Weil hier oben noch was ist okay
Da nix
Jetzt ist das level mehr oder weniger clear
Wo ist loot da unten ist loot so eins haben wir noch loot
Moment
Ach wenn ich die maus taste raus mache dann kommt auch die tap
Die map check ich das auch einser laufanimation ja
Das ist aber in dem fall ich dachte am anfang auch das hat es sich aber gut überlegt
Da muss er keine laufanimation moment
eine laufanimation machen
Aber das scheint mir echt style zu sein die die sind alle so aus ja
Ja ich habe vergessen das gold auf zusammen es liegt auch genauer auf den fußspuren complete
Wir haben es geschafft
Max punkt tv hast du eine neue domain geholt
Nice
Er ist stimmt du bist ja auch gerade am 3d animieren und modelieren
Okay
Als youtube nicht irgendwie verboten werbung für seine tutschdienste machen die haben gesagt
Dass sie nicht wollen dass videos hochgeladen wird den ihr einziger zweck ist andere plattformen zu
Promoten oder generell deren einziger zweck was ist was zu promoten das haben sie gesagt du darfst auf youtube schon noch
Dass ich auch irgendwie verstehen kann
Du darfst schon auch in community post machen jetzt mit live auf auf trittschau das identifizieren wir mal die karts
Was gibt's denn das schönes
Ein neuer karte wie wir nicht verwenden
So schlecht ich sehe gar nicht
Aber wir werden nicht so oft gestern fünfmal pro map oder so kann man das gelben koop spiel gute frage
Müssen wir gleich ins hauptmenü gucken ich weiß es nicht
Aber nachdem das early access vielleicht noch nicht
Anna pauschens brauche ich
Oh eine neue feuerachs auch das ist gut
Das ist gut
Ist das spiel mit hand of fate vergleichbar ich glaube hand of fate war mehr karten spieler als das hier
Ich bin mir bin mir aber hand of fate nicht sicher habe ich nicht gespielt aber das was ich gesehen habe sondern deutlich mehr nach karten spiel
Aber ich bin mir bin mir aber hand of fate nicht sicher habe ich nicht gespielt aber das was ich gesehen habe sondern deutlich mehr nach karten spiel
Ich bin mir hat
Ah eine neue armor
Besser als meins, ne?
Ja, das werden wir gleich mal equippen.
Okay, gut, jetzt können wir ein bisschen upgraden, noch klar.
Was braucht man denn?
Braucht man dann zum Upgraden für die Axt?
Okay, das ist schon mal ganz gut, das könnte man upgraden.
Was kostet denn die Armor zu upgraden?
Kann man beides machen.
Upgraden die Armor?
Ja, die Axt, die haben sogar, die haben sehr sehr viele Diablo-Anspielungen.
Kann ich gleich nochmal upgraden?
Wie bringt das jetzt? 60% Spawn-Hards.
Aber das kostet ein bisschen viel. Dann upgraden wir lieber die Axt.
Ja, Upgraden.
Ich benutze eh kaum Cooldowns, ich benutze fast nur Auto-Attack.
Oder das Schild nochmal upgraden, was bringt das Schild?
60% Block, oh nice, das upgraden wir.
60% Block ist Poggers.
Dann erst mal die Axt.
Und jetzt upgraden wir noch das Schild.
Zum Schild abqueren brauchen wir noch einmal was.
Truth-Rule.
Ah, das da.
Okay, das heißt ich brauche da.
Oder wie?
Das und das ergibt das, oder?
Das, das.
Jetzt upgraden wir das Schild.
70%, das ist praktisch.
70.000, Alter.
Aber 70% ist schon gut.
Sehr schön.
Kann man das noch weiter upgraden? Nee, oder?
Ah, Level 3 ist Maximum, okay. Na dann geht das ja, dann kann man alles relativ einfach upgraden.
Dann lohnt es sich auch, wenn man Legendaries findet.
Okay, gucken wir nochmal in unseren Pot.
Was gibt's? Ja gut, aufgefülltes Zeug braucht doch kein Mensch.
Ah, ein Schlüssel, praktisch.
Wahnsinn war das jetzt.
Ich meine, das können wir upgraden, das Ding, das braucht irgendwelche Karten, das vollkommen welche.
Braucht dann anscheinend 5 Mana, braucht dann 7 Mana haben wir.
Ja, Pavilion Man, ich finde auch, dass das optisch ganz gut gelungen ist.
Die haben sich einen guten Grafikstil überlegt, wie man das machen kann, ohne dass man wahnsinnig viele Ressourcen reinstecken muss.
Dieses Level 3 Upgrade wiederum ist ziemlich cool.
Egal.
Mal gucken, ob wir jetzt den kriegen.
Kann es sein, dass das nicht mehr geht?
Was ist denn Back in Town?
Was?
Wollt ihr euch merken, wie es geht?
Wie geht's?
Ich bin zu doof dafür.
So Leute, ich glaube ich muss jetzt erstmal was essen.
Oh, da fahren wir ja nichts online.
Ich werde den Friseur mal hosten.
Und wir sehen uns dann.
Muss jetzt was futtern, ich weiß 5 Stunden oder so an reicht.
War's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, CO.